this is jocko podcast number 275 with
echo charles
and me jocko willink good evening echo
good evening
i have thought about writing this for
the past 48 years
[Music]
as i wrote i felt it was important to
relate to those great soldiers
that made this such a great company
we all have a journey in life with many
crossroads
curves and offshoots the synergistic
effect
created by individual journeys coming
together at this point in time
at this location created an organization
that truly stood above the rest
the quality of an organization ebbs and
flows
with the quality of the leadership and
the dedication
personalities and expertise of the
individuals present
at a particular time during this time
period
i witnessed the synergism of the unit
only increase further with each passing
month
this story is important so that people
know who the helicopter crews were
and what they were asked to do and did
in 1964 and 65 the army ramped up the
warrant officer candidate program to
meet the expanding need for helicopter
pilots in vietnam
between 1965 and 1971
44 000 warrant officer cadets were
awarded flight wings
most were high school graduates and some
had some college
the average age of pilots crew chiefs
and door gunners
was 20 years old badly needed
they were trained quickly and given
enormous responsibility to
maintain a very complex piece of
equipment
our aircraft were not as sophisticated
as the machines today
but the uh-1d and the uh-1h
models were exceptional forgiving
workhorses
without which this war could not have
been waged
of the 5 000 uh-1 helicopters that went
to vietnam starting in 1962
over 3 300 were just
were destroyed in combat
this undeclared war also could not have
been waged
without the young men that supported
maintained
and crewed these aircraft
average age of pilots and crews 20 years
old 3
300 out of 5 000 helicopters lost in
combat
and that is a little excerpt from the
introduction of a book
called undaunted valor
an assault helicopter unit in vietnam
to 1970 the book was written by
colonel matt jackson
who served as a uh-1
also known as the huey pilot in the
227th
assault helicopter battalion in vietnam
and he also continued on in the army
after vietnam
becoming an infantry officer and
eventually commanding a battalion
during the first gulf war and conducting
the largest air assault in history
with the 101st airborne division
and it is an honor to have colonel
matt jackson here with us tonight to
discuss
his experiences and share his lessons
learned colonel thanks for coming on
thank you jocko for having me
it's pretty awesome to read your book
and then be sitting here talking to you
and before we jump into the book let's
talk about because the book
the book jumps right into basically you
enlisting
in the army let's let's go back a little
bit further than that so you were born
in
in in the navy yard in brooklyn
and your dad was a was in the navy yes
yes i was born
dad was stationed at the brooklyn navy
yard in 1947
uh he had been on submarines during the
pacific
his first ship was in lexington until it
went down and then he decided to
transfer the submarines at that because
he felt they were safer than
receiving dive bombers so so so so he
was on
he was on the court he was on what ship
in in the battle of coral sea
the lexington and it went down and he
got recovered by one of the other
vessels yeah he was in the water for
about six hours before he got picked up
by a destroyer
so then he transferred when he got out
he he went back and
transferred over to the submarine
service he thought that the submarines
would be safer
he didn't like airplanes
oh man so yeah i was born at the
brooklyn navy yard
and every three years after that for the
rest of my life until i joined the army
we moved to a different place constantly
moving around dad jumping from one
submarine to another
norfolk key west naples italy yokohama
japan
coos bay oregon so quite extensive
travel as a kid
and your dad was was an enlisted guy in
the beginning he started as enlisted he
was a
master chief i had 19 years in and then
through the ldo
program got promoted to a lieutenant jg
and stayed in until he made lieutenant
commander and he got out in 1973
uh he was commanding the navy base in
coos bay oregon
and so what was your dad like i mean was
he going on deployments all the time
when you were growing up what was that
like
yeah dad was gone a lot uh but in those
days the old diesel subs they go out for
two or three weeks and then he'd be back
in and mom ruled roost then
uh you know i've been hit with a shoe a
spatula a bell
to back of her hand uh but
dad was a disciplinarian and from a very
young
age i was taught that you say yes sir no
sir
yes ma'am no man and don't you dare get
caught lying
there was nothing that made my dad
madder than a catchy line i would get a
spanking
never got beaten but uh my little fanny
got worn out a couple of times by dad
i learned real quick uh but he was a
good man so was mom
yeah and so you're you're traveling
around all these different places
are you playing sports what's what's
like uh what are your hobbies
when you're growing up hunting uh dad
taught me to shoot when i was seven
years old
and any chance we had we'd be out on the
weekends out hunting some play squirrel
hunting or deer hunting
that was when we lived in virginia and
connecticut uh
in italy i learned to play soccer uh
because all my friends were italians
and and i learned to speak very good
italian you are comma maya houser
and that was the way i spoke italian but
yes played a lot of baseball softball
when i was a kid typical kid things
typical kid things and so what'd you do
where were you when you graduated
when you graduated from high school i
was in yokohama japan
and there i learned i learned to play
football
because we had to have every high school
kid playing in order to have a team
uh all the boys playing anyway and uh
that's where i learned judo took judo
lessons while i was over at the codacon
and uh really enjoyed my time in japan
we were there for two years and uh i
found it very enjoyable
so then when you graduated high school
was your dad looking at you
um ready to throw you out when you
turned 18 all right go you go figure it
out now
well dad said the day i graduated he
said son you have three choices
you can go to college you can go to work
or you can go in the military but the
operative word is you can go
so two days after after i graduate high
school i went back to oregon i got a job
on a login crew sitting chokers
and then went to college for a year then
the next summer i shipped out on a
merchant oil tanker
uh the ss american trader and did two
trips to from okinawa to saudi arabia on
an oil tanker
and then came back and did another year
of college and
it was a pretty worthless year so so
what year is this this is in uh
let's say i went to college in 65 in 66
i went out on the merchant mariners
and then when i came back 67 was a
worthless year
and at the end of 67 dad was coming back
from japan and we had a little
discussion about
my future and i was going to go back in
the merchant mariners he said if you do
that you'll never go back to college and
he was right i wouldn't have i love the
merchant mariners
and i said okay i'm going to join the
marine corps he said you join the marine
corps they're going to take us both to
the hospital extract by foot from your
rear end
so i thought this conversation is going
nowhere you're o for two
oh for two and he said look it you've
got a private pilot's license
why don't you go into that army warrant
officer flight program
so the next day i went down signed up so
you you had your private
pilot's license already yeah what was
that i mean how come you did that were
you just interested would you like
flying yeah the first two years i was in
high school we lived in coos bay oregon
and i got a job working at the airport
refueling airplanes
and instead of getting paid in cash i
got paid in flying lessons
so by doing that i was able to get my
private pilot's license just before we
went to japan
so you like flying and your dad says
your dad knew about this warrant officer
program
did you recognize what was going to
happen with this warrant officer program
i mean we
in that introduction that i just read
you know you're talking about the fact
that they needed
they needed pilots they needed pilots
for a reason
i mean they were they were losing them
and
did you just think okay well that's
that's that's the path i'm going to take
i thought i'm getting out of college
i really didn't think much about you
know what was happening over there we'd
see it on tv you know but
uh no i just i was determined i was
getting out of college one way or the
other and that was the path to get out
of college right then and there so
i joined up so this book undaunted valor
um there's actually there's actually
three books that you've written
called undaunted valor the first one is
this one an assault helicopter unit in
vietnam the next one is called
uh medal of honor and then lamsan
719 that's volume one two and three
so in this book you
the way you explain to me or the way
that i understand it
is that this first book volume one
you're the lead character even though
the lead character has a different name
dan corey
that's that's this is your story that's
correct and i mean it's real
i mean uh if you were trying to cover it
up you didn't do a great job because
like
dan corey's dad was a master chief who
became an officer uh
then you know he grew up in all these
different places and
so you didn't do a good is there a
reason why you said you know what i'm
going to change my name in this book
it's just because my attorneys said that
uh you want to change your name you
don't want to use your real name yeah
uh in the book so that's the reason i i
come up with dan corey
did you did you pull dan cory out of
anyone was that a name that meant
anything
uh corey was a good friend of mine in
college
and uh dan i just kind of pulled that
one out of the air or so
right on uh so we're gonna jump into
this first book here
a little bit and well
here we go okay first chapter is called
it begins
it says raising our right hands we all
took the oath of allegiance
those of us that were flight school
wannabes were escorted to a waiting cab
that was to take us
to the airport we were there were
anti-war protesters blocking the front
door
so we went out the back through an
abandoned storefront
instead of bands playing as we went off
to combat as our grandfathers had
experienced
we were sneaking out the back door
that's correct
this is back in uh let's see this would
have been february of 68
and in portland oregon at that time as
today
uh they had demonstrators outside the
mep station all in front of the mep
station
so what they had is the mep station had
a back door that went through an
abandoned storefront
and they would take us in and bring us
out through that back door
so that we didn't have to put up with
the protesters that were out front yeah
and you said as your grandfather as your
grandparents went off the water but this
is actually
your parents your dad went off the war
well my dad and my grandfather my
grandfather was in
uh destroyers in world war one uh served
in the navy
back then and went to the big wars
oh man uh fast forward a little bit
you get to boot camp highlight this one
section of boot camp the hill
was a hundred yard dirt and gravel field
with a
steep slope of 50 feet at one end
we were lined up by squad in four ranks
of 10 on command we had to crawl to the
top of the slope
when i reached the top my hands knees
and elbows were raw for the next three
days we revisited the hill
each evening before chow on the third
day i was really feeling sorry for
myself
suddenly i had to come to jesus moment
hey dumbass
you volunteered to be here you weren't
drafted you quit college and volunteered
for this [ __ ]
so stop your crying and suck it up yeah
yeah it was the hill would say yeah it
was kind of a frightening thing now you
as a seal sitting there you're chuckling
because you think my god what a bunch of
wimps going
but uh you know a bunch of guys that
just got muslim were draftees and
we were in a state of shock because that
was a the very first day in basic
training you spent five days in
reception station
and they treated you so nice and then
you get over to the the company and oh
my god the drill sergeants were
devouring us
and so we start up this hill and i'm
thinking oh my god this is
you know this is killing my knees it was
all stones knees are getting torn up
hands are getting torn up
and on the third day i had the you know
premonition came suck it up so so you're
going to boot camp with
just everyone just normal everyone
that's going in the army oh yeah yeah
there's no there's no special treatment
because you're going in this warrant
officer program no
basic training was uh you were thrown in
with everybody draftees
national guard reservists uh regular
army guys enlisted
and you all went to fort puke louise uh
fort polk louisiana
uh fast forward a little bit you get
done with basic training and
look you've got all this is the thing i
always have to make this statement
i'm not reading the whole book people if
you got to get the book to get all of it
but so when i when it might sound like
it's jumping around it is jumping around
i'm just jumping through sections
the story you got you got a bunch of
great stories in here and and they're
just
tons of lessons learned i'm gonna fast
forward a little bit you get done with
basic training
and then you go to pre-flight and you
say basic training taught us discipline
pre-flight is going to teach us
attention to detail
cadet brady trade the 1800 briefing
welcome to pre-flight i'm a holdover
from a previous previous class
so me and the other cadets were directed
to meet you and get you settled in
after tomorrow morning we're just like
you and in this with you
first formation will be at 0 5 30 and it
will be frightening
our tac officers our warrant officers
who finished their flying tours in
vietnam
now they're babysitting us instead of
being instructor pilots and they're not
happy about it
you can expect to get your ass smoked in
the morning nothing you do will make
them happy so be prepared
for it this is my second time going
through this and i'll try to laugh my
way through tomorrow morning
because it's the only thing to do he
explained yeah that's all you could do
they they smoked us that first morning
in fact they smoked this all the way
through preflight and the the big thing
at pre-flight and
we didn't realize at the time was
attention to detail
uh because the quickest thing that'll
get you killed in a helicopter is a
broken safety wire
or a bolt that that's turned and the
slippage marks aren't lined up
so that's what they were adamant about
there in preflight is teaching you
attention to detail how much detail
at the end of the third week we had to
take our belt buckles apart
our brass belt buckles and clean the
inside
to get the penicillin out or they'd be
tearing their belt buckles apart
um your shoes your low quarter shoes you
had to be sure and take a black nitrogen
marker
and go around the outside to cover up
any any
stitching that it turned white your
uniforms you had to take black magic
marker
on your uniforms or your name tags rack
and make sure that that thread
hadn't turned any white toothbrush you
better be sure there's no leftover
toothpaste inside that toothbrush
uh it was all those kinds of things that
uh that they went through and and
uh it paid off i mean it really paid off
once we got to the flight line though
the idea of attention to detail
yeah the um that's that's a common
theory i went to uh
navy boot camp and i don't think it was
as stringent as that but
and officer candidates school the same
thing attention to detail's huge and i
remember
they have uh the drill instructors at
officer candidate school they have a
they walk around with a metal ruler in
their pocket
and they're measuring your folded
underwear
to make sure that they are whatever it
was four and three quarters inches by
four and three quarter inches perfect
square that's what it's got to be and
it's out you fail
attention to detail ours was uh rolled
underwear at nine inches
there you go so and they they had the
rulers
[Music]
and if they didn't like it you'd come
back and that barracks would be torn
apart
bids be upside down mattresses upside
down everything out of foot lockers and
tack officer be standing there waiting
for you god help you
uh again i hate to fast forward through
so much good stuff but i have to
on the flight school we did get a pay
raise coming to flight school as we were
promoted from e1 or e2 privates to e5
sergeants
our pay went from 98 to 225
a month almost all extra pay went to two
things
haircuts and laundry bills yep every
day uh you'd spend half a day on the
flight line in a flight suit it was
those gray flight suits
uh over from the 60s that air force wore
navy war and orange one the other half
of the day
you're in fatigues starch fatigues
and they better not be broken over from
yesterday you'd better be breaking
starch every day
and they would start so bad that you had
to work at getting your leg
down your pants or your arm down the
sleeve i mean it was
it was brutal starch but by god you had
to do that every day and
between haircuts and the laundry bill
there went your pay raise right there
so that lasted well and i know you were
in the army until the 90s but
when i came in the navy and when i got
the seal team and when i was going
through basic seal training the same
thing
which is freaking crazy because that is
the most pointless
thing in the world to have
combat uniforms starched
and i think it was the marine corps god
bless them
was the first service that i saw where
they said look
you don't starch those uniforms and they
started just looking like
normal clothes which was a good thing
i remember i remember when the army got
away from it i think it was in the the
mid 70s
that you know you don't need to start
your fatigues anymore and then
definitely when the
the bdus came out it was a big no known
to get those things starched so
i was glad to see that i wish the navy
would have known that because i had
starch bdus for the first 10 years of my
career
absolutely as a matter of fact my son
was going through some of my old gear
the other day and he was
picking up a pair i had a pair of pants
they're freaking 20 or 30 years old
and they're still you could put them on
inspection ready they had so much damage
in them uh boom
once we completed fleet pre-flight
training we
entered primary flight training at any
one time in 1968 there were 10
flight companies in session you ended up
you you get to pick well you i guess you
draw what kind of helicopter you're
gonna fly
now you're told okay you get you're told
and you get the th55
love that aircraft looks like uh uh
looks like kind of a dragonfly looking
yeah it's the
this it was bought the army bought them
right off the shelf from hughes aircraft
and it's in the civilian world it's a
hughes 300.
you you started the engine up and then
you engaged the clutch which engaged
eight rubber bands
that started turning the main rotor and
uh so we got that going for us yeah i
got them before
but the thing had a ton of power and
down here in texas in the summer
the oh-13s and the 23s the other two
training aircraft
they could barely get off the ground
th55 would spring off the ground so
it was just a great little aircraft to
fly i loved it
awesome
about two months into our flight
training we returned from the flight
line and we were told to get
in company formation right away once all
275 of us were assembled
as we'd have had about 75 drop out the
class at this point our company
commander came forward and addressed the
class
one of our fellow classmates crashed
that day and was killed
that was something none of us had
considered at this point in our training
his death would not be the last either
another student and his flight
instructor were killed in a mid-air
collision
with another aircraft flown by someone
from another class
how there weren't a lot more merit
mid-air collisions always amazed me
a little bit of a wake-up call well it
was you know you had
roughly around 1200 aircraft at eight
o'clock in the morning leaving
and coming back in at 11 o'clock and
then leaving again at one o'clock and
coming back at five o'clock
and most of them were flown by students
so you know the students had anywhere
from
10 hours to 50 hours or let's say you
got
yeah you got 100 hours total while
you're in in
flight school early flight school first
stage there so
you had a lot of inexperience out there
running around and not that big of an
area
and why we didn't have a lot more air
midairs i have no idea
the uh the one student the first student
that we lost he flew into a cloud
and we hadn't had any weather instrument
training yet at that point well he went
in the cloud and
people that saw me came out upside down
he was inverted
and uh you just don't invert in a
helicopter it doesn't work
so that he got killed that way then the
other one was a student an instructor
and another aircraft slammed into them
uh we lost them there those are the only
two that i knew about there were others
that that did happen in other flight
classes
but we were kind of fortunate we started
out with 350
we graduated i think one 150 somewhere
in that neighborhood there
uh i get done with that it's on to
advanced flight training
um this was i
i kind of had to there's there's a good
leadership lesson here that i wanted to
jump into
it says we're approaching the end of our
instrument training when we returned to
the barracks from the flight line
the night prior to the meteor
meteorology
exam mr clinton wasn't happy with the
condition of the barracks
and had gone on a rampage aided by a
bottle of jack daniels
beds were overturned wall locker
contents were fl were lying on the floor
the fire hose was spraying water and the
contents of everyone's foot lockers were
everywhere except in the foot lockers he
was on a tirade
one cadet was singled out mr clinton was
berating him
evidently the cadet was responsible for
his five o'clock shadow
mr clinton told the cadet to get into
the push-up position
once there he placed a razor on the
floor in front of him and told him to
shave
the cadet looked scared and i was mad i
had had enough of mr clinton's crap
with all respect for his rank that i
could muster i stepped forward and
gotten clinton's face
sir you've been drinking and you are
drunk if you do not leave this minute i
am going straight to the company
commander and have him resolve this
situation now
leave i shouted there was dead silence
mr clinton just stood there and glared
at me with his bloodshot eyes everyone
was watching
finally he laughed turned and staggered
out of the barracks
everyone including me sighed with relief
we spent most of the night getting the
barracks back in order
and no one had an opportunity to study
for the weather exam
it showed the next day the exam was in
the morning when we returned to the
barracks after flying in the afternoon
we were immediately informed by the
company first sergeant
that we were all restricted to the
barracks until further notice and i was
to report to the company commander's
office
when i arrived the senior officer from
the weather committee was present as
well
i was told to sit down cadet corey
do you know why i've restricted the
company and called you here the company
commander asked
like i was some clairvoyant and i could
read his mind
this was the first time i'd ever spoken
to the man again
dad's words of wisdom came to mind no
sir
i replied knowing this wasn't the time
to be a smartass
it appears cadet corey that most of your
class failed the weather exam
we need to know why he stated oh [ __ ]
most of the class which includes me too
again as class leader it was my fault
didn't you study for the exam last night
asked the weather committee instructor
who didn't look happy
why did i suspect that [ __ ] rolled
downhill here and it was coming right at
me
however i was seeing a u-turn for this
[ __ ] storm
no sir we did not study last night we
had a party instead
i replied their eyes bulged and i
thought both men were going to drop dead
from heart attacks you did what gag the
company commander you had a party the
night before the most
one of the most important exams in this
course do you realize by by having a
party and failing that exam you could
all fail flight school and be sent to
infantry immediately
yes sir i replied and let them stew on
this revelation
now the weather instructor had a grin on
his face as he turned to the company
commander
well i guess the problem wasn't with the
instruction but with the discipline of
these cadets
i was beginning to see what was going on
here somewhere above their level the
[ __ ] had hit the fan and someone high up
was looking for
somewhere to lay the blame the army
needed helicopter pilots at this point
had spent considerable money training 80
cadets
the army couldn't afford to wash out 80
cadets at one time the company commander
wasn't looking too good right about now
cadet corey why in the hell would you
have a party the night before a major
exam
sir we had no choice i answered
sheepishly i was beginning to enjoy this
i had been around the military long
enough to know when people would have
stayed a panic over something
that had gone terribly wrong oh dad you
taught me well what the hell do you mean
you had no choice the company commander
sir when we returned from flightline
last night mr clinton had
torn apart the barracks to include
turning on the fire hose and told us to
get the mess cleaned up before
morning we had a barracks cleaning party
to get it squared away and that took
until midnight
light out lights out was at 2200 but we
worked on stuff until dark
until we had it taken care of only the
married men had a chance to study last
night
you're dismissed cadet corey and there
you go so you
you you then up you know you go to the
company commander then you end up with a
battalion commander
and the school commandant and the school
commandant finally
uh you end up all assembled
the battalion commander comes out i am
lieutenant colonel barlow your battalion
commander i have not met most of you and
normally do not meet cadets
until graduation however because this
incident i have met some of you and
thought i should meet all of you
what you've experienced is not typical
of the treatment of cadets
changes have been made the first being
that you have a new company commander
major kid or will be your company
commander for the remainder of your
training
mr clinton sergeant first class [ __ ]
will no
longer be your tax either major kitter
and he turns it over
the uh to back up a little bit
our class got a bad rap the first the
very first day we showed up
me and another guy we had flown into
savannah the night before
so we had a 1200 hour report him and i
got there at about 11.
so we we report on time the rest of the
guys
they all flew in on a flight that was
supposed to land at 8 o'clock in the
morning but didn't because of the
weather
so they all showed up an hour late so
that set clinton off and for eight weeks
we never got a pass to get off the base
where every other class had blanket
passes on the weekends
and so clinton and and the man had had a
drinking problem and this wasn't the
first incident with him but this is the
one that broke campbell's back
uh when he when he went through that
that
weather exam as as i said in the book
you couldn't afford to flunk 79 guys
right now somebody was gonna go
ballistic over this
so it worked its way up and thank god
when we got to the brigade commander's
office and
they asked me they said why do you think
mr clinton did that and i said
well sir because he was drunk well
the three of them looked at me like do
you know what you just said you accused
an
officer of this well i was a little bit
older than most cadets i
i joined the army i was 21 the day i
came in and
all the other classmates they were 19 20
year olds
and been around the military all my life
i had an idea how things worked
so i was i was going to play my trump
card and that's and that's where i
played the trump card was with the
brigade commander
you know over the next couple of days
they called in every day they call in
three guys
and they'd ask them the same questions
and and everybody backed my
my comments up so uh we got mr clinton
got rid of mr clinton got just
rid of sergeant [ __ ] and i use the name
sergeant [ __ ]
i never heard the guy ever speak he had
he had tattoos covering him everywhere
before tattoos were popular and
so i don't know anything about the man
outside of he never said anything so i
figured it was more
uh but then after that we we went into
our advanced training
uh huey transition was the following
monday morning and and things went along
really well after that with the unit
major kid him it was a
he was a great guy how did you like that
huey when you started flying it oh i
loved it
i still love the huey to this day the
huey is a fantastic aircraft
had plenty of power even the delta
models had plenty of power they were
forgiving
they were just they were a dream to fly
and they still are
uh isn't it great oh i guess it's not
too crazy i mean i joined the navy in
and we still had huey's and they're
still huey's right now
uh the army's put all layers in museums
what about the marine corps
uh the marine corps has got a different
huey they got a big beefed up one okay
muscular thing so it's twin engines and
i'm not sure if it's got four rotor
blades or just two but
uh they've got a beefed up huey that's
much much bigger than the armies ever
wore
so it's great aircraft i mean why
wouldn't still be using today i don't
know
i mean we got the blackhawks now yeah
they're way bigger
i mean they're way smaller than a
blackhawk though oh yeah yeah tiny
we could get uh we could get six combat
troops
uh besides the crew crew four aboard and
had power to you know to do things and
stuff like that
the blackhawk when we assaulted into
iraq uh
back during desert storm uh there was 15
guys in my aircraft with me
and uh my rtos my and i had one squad of
infantrymen with me we went in so
much more power much more a much faster
aircraft and it was an aircraft the
blackhawk i was on
the test bed for it they were designed
in case we went into war with iran
and that's that's really what we were
looking at for an aircraft they could
get the altitude
uh the mountain is out mount altitude
around iran
uh to replace the huey and the blackhawk
was the
the choice over it they were two there
was a boeing put a proposal up for the
utas
and then sikorsky put a proposal up for
the utas it was called utas
at that time utility tactical transport
system
and uh sikorsky's the one that won so
and it seems like
when you look at the the huey it's like
a freaking 1969
muscle car just in terms of hey that's
the engine
there's you know you see the the the uh
aircraft now the helicopters
there's so many computer parts too it's
like when you open up the hood of a car
nowadays you don't know what the hell's
in there right it's all
you can't you can't fix any of it with a
wrench well you look at you look at the
huey who's the guy crewing the huey
the guy was eight 19 years old maybe 20
and he was the crew chief
and what those kids did with those
engines was just amazing they'd work on
them and
you know i was a pilot and the most
dangerous thing you could do is let the
pilot up there around the engine
my crew chief wouldn't dare do that but
uh these kids
they really maintained those things well
and what what they couldn't do at the
operator level
at the crew chief level they went into
the the maintenance level which is right
there with our unit and they were all 19
and 20 year olds doing the sheet metal
work and the electronics
i took a bullet through the through the
wiring bundle one day
and the wiring bundle was about that
thick
and it was maybe 35-40 white wires in
there
and i saw a kid sit down and sit there
and put each one of those wires back
properly to each one of them to get the
get the communications and
the electronics all working to me it was
a bunch of spaghetti
jack so um
let's fast forward a little bit let's
get to let's get to vietnam
um the flight from fort lewis washington
to vietnam was 14 hours with a two-hour
stop
uh at yokota air force base outside of
tokyo japan
the plane was a commercial airliner
contract by the government most air
force transport aircraft were carrying
cargo and not passengers we arrived in
cameron bay vietnam in the dead of night
jumping forward a little bit you get to
where you're going
a jeep came just and look in order to
get there i gotta bypass all the
a bunch of good stuff get the book uh a
jeep came to stop in front of me with a
hatless captain driving you mr corey
yes sir i snapped to a chance attention
and saluted and saluted
[ __ ] you trying to get me shot damn
sniper sees you doing that i'm i'm gonna
be the one that's gonna get shot
don't you i don't have a hat on for a
reason so get your [ __ ] and let's go
he said with a disgusted tone sorry sir
i tossed my duffel bags into the jeep
and climbed in
he extended his hand and grinned there's
no snipers here just thought i'd scare
the crap out of you
i'm captain good night uh the operations
officer for our merry band welcome to
the chicken coop the chicken coop is the
company
location and this here is the parking
area and the is the chicken pen
our call sign is chicken man chicken man
that's our call sign i responded
that'll ought to instill the courage in
the hearts of our troops and fear in the
minds of the enemy
why couldn't it be something bold and
dynamic i thought chicken man sir how
did we come by that call sign i asked
the official call sign is drumstick
there's a popular radio show in the
chicago area and now it's
on armed forces radio in vietnam about a
wicked
white winged warrior called chicken man
some of the episodes are hilarious
when the unit first came to nam we were
the hoot owls and the name has changed
several times over the years to apache
and lucky shot in 1966
sidewinder and swordfish in 1967 and
drumstick in 1968
some of the warrant officers decided
about six months ago to start using
chicken man call sign
and it's pretty much stuck so now it's
the unofficial call sign for the unit
i was starting to like this chicken man
call sign now
the uh that you gotta you gotta
understand warrant officers back then
uh again they're all 19 year olds
some were 18 20 year olds
and it's the 60s so you know once you
got out of flight school
your hair regulation kind of slipped and
you're trying to grow a mustache when
you don't have any hair to grow a
mustache
and what are they going to do to you
bend your dog tags and send you to
vietnam
you're already there so foreign officers
were kind of a rebellious bunch
to the army we had the warrant officer
protection association
that you know if something was going
right in the unit all the warrants would
get together and [ __ ] about it
but so when they when they came up with
this name drumstick
everybody did you know thought oh my god
what a stupid name
and then the chicken man series started
on afvn
and then it stuck and even after
uh they changed the name drumstick
officially
[Music]
chicken man chicken man we still kept
the chicken man call sign
we never gave it up and like on the
front of the book there it's got a
picture of
the aircraft with the chicken on the
nose and
we never took the chickens off the nose
uh awesome so you're going through kind
of
in doc learning what's going on there
and and
and finally we get to this how much how
much flying are we getting i asked
every newbie asked that question captain
goodnight chimed in
you'll get all the flying you want and
more than you can handle
there'll be days when you go to bed with
your butt cheeks hurting and they'll
still be hurting when you wake up
and you have another 12 to 15 hour day
ahead of you some days you'll get 20
hours in before you shut the engine down
normally when you get 140 hours for the
month you get a two-day stand down
if i don't need you here explained is
another
individual walk-in this is lou price
he's going to show you
where you can set up housekeeping lou
price was probably absolutely one of the
best helicopter pilots i ever knew
uh lou was
21 years old his first mission in
vietnam was about six
about eight months before i got there
and it was into the oshawa valley
he flew in and he walked out because his
aircraft landed upside down
and he had to punch his way through the
greenhouse bubble they were shot down
going in and the aircraft rolled
uh lou he left after the year
and in the book as you see he came back
about eight months later he said
vietnam was a hell of a lot safer than
being an instructor at flight school
and lou stayed for the next year
and he had been discharged from the army
and was still flying in vietnam they had
to get a marine escort i mean a
mps court to come and get him and take
him back and it was because
the first cab division had left all of
our personnel records had left
and so they didn't know how much time
anybody had left in the unit
so luke just he was enjoying it he was
flying his beard drinking and flying his
helicopter drinking his beer
had nothing better to do so luke just
stayed and finally they had
bringing mps up to get him out of there
lou uh he
got out and last i heard lou had been a
financial advisor to a major corporation
before he passed away but he was a great
pilot
awesome um you did note in here that
there was uh
the latest led zeppelin song was playing
on a real real tape player oh yeah
he's wild i was talking to this so i
have a son who's uh 18 years old
and he listens to metallica
so when i was thinking about this
the first led zeppelin album came out
like 1968.
i was born in 1971 and and and when i
grew up led zeppelin seemed
really old right they seemed so old i
mean i love led zeppelin but they seemed
like they were way before my time
well my son was born in 2002.
the first metallica album came out in
1983.
that's all so like way before he he's
way older
than metallica he's much much further
away from metallica's beginning than i
was from led zeppelin's
opening you know it's really crazy how
that time goes by
but you guys were there in the in the
thick of it listening to some zeppelin
has your side ever hurting god of david
oh yeah oh yeah i love playing on guitar
i still i still play it around the house
my wife looks at me she goes oh we're
gonna have one of those moments
[Laughter]
this is always a good a good thing to do
here you just kind of talk about some of
the characters the pilots were a mixed
bag
most of the warren officers fell into
one of three categories either high
school graduates college dropouts or
former ncos that had gone to flight
school
most of the warrants were bachelors with
girlfriends back in the states except
the old guys
who were married with wives and two kids
back in the states the commissioned
officers
or as you call them real live officers
or rlos
as warrants referred to them we're all
college graduates
but i didn't notice any west pointers in
the unit you could spot them by the
large
ring on their finger hence the nickname
ring knockers
although no one did pt there were no
overweight pilots
most were attempting to grow mustaches
with limited success we were all just
too baby-faced
most of the crew chiefs and maintenance
personnel were volunteers
who had enlisted rather than waiting to
be drafted there were 29 draftees
the most and most were door gunners who
had volunteered to extend for door
gunner duty to cut their draft time
short or to put more money in their
pockets before going home
all were prior grunts they were all good
soldiers
there was an occasional drunk and
disorderly and maybe an occasional pot
use
but i couldn't recall any specific cases
of a lack of discipline
if pot was being smoked it was kept
pretty quiet and infrequent
the the crews that the crews in the unit
were just they're fantastic kids
uh the door gunners they
they most of those guys i think just
about every one of them was an infantry
guy
who volunteered to come and serve as a
door gunner and they were an essential
part of the aircraft
not only did they take care of the guns
on the aircraft they also assisted the
crew chief in
cleaning the aircraft and running the
engine stuff like that
the pilots as i said you know college
dropouts most of us
or the old guys and the old guys they
were we tried to give them the easy
missions but they never took them
they they stepped right up to the plate
like everybody else uh
fortunately we only lost
two or three guys in my time there that
were married men uh my roommate dave
hannah
another two other guys that that i knew
real well that we lost but
both of them were married guys uh the
crew chiefs
uh all of those guys had gone they had
enlisted four crew chief
duty and they had gone to the the
maintenance course
and came back over um really a great
bunch of guys and i still uh keep in
touch with several of them
commissioned officers the rlos the real
live officers as
us warrant officers referred to them
most of them were pretty good guys
uh we had one or two that were
less than stellar let me put it that way
but most of them were really really
pretty good uh
our maintenance our maintenance officer
was fantastic and i still
uh communicate with him quite frequently
um
the the operations officer he i talked
to him a lot
he was good um even our previous
operations officer who left the day i
got there
uh howard burbank he kind of heads up
our
reunions and everything's a great guy so
most of the officers were really
fantastic
and easy to work with in the unit
aircraft commander didn't make a
difference what your rank was
you had to earn the seat to be an
aircraft commander and it took four
months of flying time
and a vote of confidence by all of the
existing aircraft commanders before you
got that honor
did it make a difference if you're a
warrant officer or if you were an rlo
if you didn't cut the mustard you didn't
get in the left seat and
they held that pretty pretty pretty
steady through my entire time there it
was
and it was good there was a lot of
respect for aircraft commanders
everybody understood how it worked if
you're an rlo
you're going to be in the right seat
until you get voted to be in the left
seat and
it worked well
as you're kind of learning the um the
the ropes of what's going on there
you're talking to a guy
sergeant first class robertson like like
an ops guy i guess you guys called him
pops he's a good man he lays some stuff
out for you um what are most of the
missions that we fly i asked sir it's a
bit of everything
you may start the day off flying ash and
trash resupply for a battalion followed
by being
part of a 6-2 combat assault followed by
flying knight hunter killer or chuck
chuck
chuck chuck i ask command and control a
battalion commander will jump aboard
with his staff usually a fire support
officer and fly around the circle
flying a circle around a unit in contact
while the battalion commander directs
artillery fire
boring as hell for you generally what's
a 6-2 i asked
a 6-2 is a flight of six hueys and two
cobras the cobras will come from our
delta company on the other side of the
chicken pen
they refer to their area as the snake
pit and hunter killer that's a fun one
three aircraft
a cobra flying at about a thousand feet
a huey full of flares flying at about a
thousand feet
following the cobra and a huey flying
between the ground and 500 feet
nice and slow with lights on so charlie
can see you and shoot at you
the low bird is equipped with a 50
caliber machine gun replacing one of the
m60 guns and a searchlight with a low
angle
with a low light intensity night vision
scope
on top is mounted in the cargo door
if the little bird sees something or
gets shot at the cobra rolls hot on it
and the flare aircraft starts dropping
flares so the cobra can see targets
want some more coffee yes please
how do you get our how do you get how do
you get missions
during the night and generally before
200 hours the maintenance officer will
tell us how many birds we can put up
for the next day we pass that to
battalion sometimes
around zero 200 battalions start sending
the missions to us captain goodnight
comes in about 0-400 and assigns the
pilots on the missions
and we start waking everyone up
generally we get the birds in the air at
first light
most of the birds aren't
instrument-rated so that can be a
problem in the monsoon season which will
begin in about three months
when do i get to fly i know what you're
thinking and that's good
but enjoy sitting on the ground for as
long as you can but because once you're
cleared you'll get all the flying you
want and then some
yeah you did get all the flying you
wanted some that was one thing that was
interesting to me and i guess i kind of
knew it but not this clearly
you you you guys did everything whether
it was logistics runs whether it was
supporting
assaults you were doing everything
everything you did every the only thing
you didn't do is operate as a gunship
because we weren't equipped to be a
gunship there was aircraft specifically
before that
but everything else in medevac it wasn't
common
for the slicks to fly medevac missions
unless it was really an emergency
and why is that well we didn't we
weren't equipped with medics or any
medical supplies on board we had little
first aid kits and that was about
it so they would try to get the medevac
birds to come in and take care of them
now
uh they had medevac birds and dust off
dust
medevac birds were part of the first
cavalry division and the 101st
airborne division they were equipped
with guns
had the big red cross on the sides but
they had guns on board
dustoff had the red cross on the side
but they had no guns and they were part
of the 44th medical brigade
so that was the difference between the
two and people hear the term dust off
from medevac well which one was which
well
that was the difference between them the
only time i ever flew medevac is when i
was actually supporting a ground unit
with a log mission and they got hit at
the same time
and i came back in and they threw on a
bunch of guys that were wounded
and i flew them out but that was about
it for a medevac mission
uh the missions we didn't like that
medevac wouldn't fly
is pulling the bodies out medevac
wouldn't touch a
body we had to fly those out so we did
those but everything else we did it all
resupply cnc 900 killer i love 900
killer
i'd fly the low bird i didn't want to
fly that flair berg one bit
uh so isn't the low bird the one that's
the bait
yeah the look like that one i like that
one the flare bird
he just orbits around up there he's
getting bored
and the bad thing is he's carrying 20
1 million power candles oh
yeah these huge huge flares don't want
to take a trace around and then he takes
the trace around that bird's burning
and the fact they carried them in 55
gallon drums out on the skids
that were held on by straps so that they
did take a round
they would take the machetes and cut
those straps and drop and try to drop
all that stuff right away
so i i never want to fly the flare bird
low bird i love flying the low bird that
was fun
bait bait
fast forward a little bit sleep came
quick and i dreamt of pleasant things
as i hadn't been in country though long
enough to have bad dreams
as i slumbered i began to dream about
the jet i heard coming for
coming in for a landing on our airstrip
it was getting louder and louder and
holy [ __ ] jets can't land here i was on
the floor of our tent with everyone else
when the rocket impacted behind our tent
followed by a second
impacting the vip landing pad behind the
majors 10. incoming i heard as i grabbed
my flak jacket
and my helmet i was half running half
crawling to the bunker in my boxer
shorts
when another rocket impacted with the
flash spraying shrapnel
diving through the door of the bunker i
plowed into someone in total darkness of
the bunker
and got shoved to the other side hey
watch it man someone said anyone seen
the new guy
i recognized lou's voice over here lou i
answered
this your first rocket attack new guy he
asked well yeah i've only been here for
two days
is this common i asked yep almost
nightly and since this is your first
you get to buy the beer be sure the
refrigerator stock tomorrow morning
when we come back in the darkness the
sounds of laughter could be heard
over the sounds of impacting rockets and
secondary explosions
any time you did something for the first
time you had to buy a case of beer case
beer
and that was the cost of learning so i
bought a lot of beer just like
everybody else those first couple of
months yeah yeah those 122 rockets they
uh they weren't accurate but boy they
would sure wake you up and
just you know create havoc for your
evening uh they were always trying to
shoot at the
the runway or at the chicken coop snake
pit area
and every once in a while we lost an
aircraft to want to slam in there
the mortars they were accurate and we
did not like getting the mortar rounds
in
and you may bring it up later on but uh
yeah the mortars the uh the barber our
barber was
the one that was registering the mortar
rounds on us
um well casey beer so yeah that was
i don't know i don't know when that i
don't know where that came from but when
i got the seal teams
same thing oh there's your first time
jumping cool quesadilla oh your first
time doing a fast rub cool quesadilla oh
your first time what uh you know first
time shooting an mp5 yep okay so beer
so they got their beer out of us that's
for sure
uh in the air at last
uh now you're flying and um you get the
you get the
aircraft turned over to you okay dan
your turn
oh wow it was dan and tony now cause
you're on a first name basis i have the
aircraft tony
you have the aircraft he responded
indicating he recognized i had positive
control of the aircraft
with my left hand on the collective
right hand on the cyclic
my whole hand i started coming up on the
power
the aircraft broke ground oh [ __ ]
screamed the door gunner we're gonna die
wailed the crew chief as and i was
[ __ ] my pants
all right you two knock it off tony said
to the crew they were laughing their
asses off
oh sure can't we screw with the new guy
yeah they did that to me well of course
they did it to every new guy too so
uh like i said the crew chiefs and door
gunners they're a bunch of jokesters
and if they if they could jerk your
chain they jerky chain all in good fun
though so
uh you talk about doing combat auto
rotations
loved it so explain the auto rotation
and then what what gets different on the
on the combat automatically okay
in flight school they teach you how to
do the standard army issue auto rotation
1 000 feet over the approaching the
runway
chop the throttle pull the nose back to
a 60 knot air speed
put the collective down completely let
the aircraft fall
75 feet from the ground you flare the
aircraft and pop the collective
as the aircraft continues to settle you
level the skids and come in with the
rest of the power to set it down on the
ground
just love doing auto rotations so the
purpose of an auto rotation is you have
some
something wrong with your aircraft yeah
the engine the engine quits
and you you can you can land an aircraft
you can land a helicopter safely
without an engine yeah yeah it's
basically the momentum of the helicopter
blades
that's right they're just spinning and
they keep spinning because they've been
spinning really fast
and then as you come down does the does
the air keep them spinning as you come
down keeps them
spinning in fact when you execute that
flare you've got to pop that collector
or you're going to get an overspeed on
your rotor head
so you pop the collective and that that
keeps from the rotor speed and going out
you want to keep your rotor
in the green at 6 600 rpm and
no correction at 335 our 345 rpm engines
at 66.
so you keep it at 345 when you flare
you're going to go well above that 345
so you pop that collective
and then that lets you settle the
aircraft down and then when you get to
about four feet off the ground you come
in with the rest of it as you level the
skids
easy set down you don't want to try to
parachute out of a helicopter with no
engine
you might get beat up on the blades so
nobody wears a parachute to exit a
helicopter
in an emergency a combat auto rotation
there's a thing in the book called the
dead zone and pilots have to know the
dead zone there's a certain area
that if you don't have air speed and
altitude air speed or altitude
you're going to die you want to have air
speed or you want to have altitude
if you can have both you're better off
but you have to keep
one of those too the combat auto
rotations especially the low level one
you'd come at a tree top level
at 90 knots air speed and chop the
throttle right then
and just start your flare and just as
the aircraft comes over
where you want to touch down you keep
the flare going keep the flare going
keep the flare going
and pull the power in and set it down i
love doing low level level rotations
they were so much fun
then you get the advanced stage you do
the 180 auto rotation
1000 feet chop the throttle take the
aircraft
turn it in a tight turn and come down or
what i was taught by a guy that was a
test pilot at the
bell helicopter 1000 feet chop the
throttle
zero the air speed do a pedal turn
punch the nose straight to the ground
build up your rotor rpm
and just do a normal touchdown and you
can do that at 360 too
and a 360 save me one time
are you so like how many times when when
you start trying to do the combat
auto rotation how many times do you try
this before you've got it
uh about three or four times
you do enough auto rotations in flight
school that you've got the basics for an
auto rotation down pat
and you go up with an experienced pilot
and they'll run you through a couple of
times and
you'll have no problem then again two
once you become an ac
you can do auto rotations whenever you
want you don't have to worry about an
instructor pilot sitting next to you and
we would do that we would go out and
when we were coming back at night after
a mission let's do an auto rotation
let's go shoot some auto rotations
so you practice those things constantly
when you're coming back in but now today
they don't even teach touchdown auto
rotations i don't think
why is that i have no idea what do you
do if you
lose power i think they teach them the
auto rotation
but they make them put the power in
before they get to the ground and
set it down but i had heard that they
don't teach touchdowns anymore they
don't let them take them
take them all the way to the ground how
much does a
how much does an hh-60 cost oh god
how much does a huey cost a huey right
now you can get by huey for about 500
thousand what about nom i mean what
about in this time period
oh in this time period i think there
were 250 250 000 and
i mean what's your best guess on a
blackhawk probably somewhere in the
neighborhood of about eight or nine
hundred thousand
right that's just a guess yeah oh that's
way cheaper than i thought
i'm gonna have to i'm gonna have to
check that one out yeah i'm not i'm not
sure
roger seems like the huey was way way
way cheaper oh it is there's nothing
sophisticated about healing
i mean engine was simple the l-13 engine
a great engine
but nothing no complicated computer
electronics in it
you had just standard flight instruments
and none of it was computerized no
computer chips
very simple aircraft to work on and a
simple aircraft to fly
and it was an amazing aircraft to fly it
would take uh
so many hits that and it still keep
going the the biggest i saw was a friend
of mine al hass
uh bill hess he got hit
and i covered it in one of the books i i
forget which one it's covered in
he had 107 bullet holes in his aircraft
one of which was a 50 caliber round that
went through the uh
the the frame right above the pilot's
head in fact uh
one of our canadian lieutenants um he
had gotten shot
in the groin and it leaned forward and
when he did that 50 caliber round hit
the
the post and if he hadn't leaned forward
he would hit him in the head
but yeah but he had 107 rounds in that
aircraft and the aircraft still flew
uh another thing that you do over there
is the combat takeoff
yes so what's the combat takeoff all
about okay a nice a nice flight school
type helicopter takeoff
is you come to a three foot hover you
pull your power you drop your nose
and you climb out at a nice rate of
climb combat helicopter take off
you pull that power in and you shove
that nose over at the same time
and so you're coming out of there like a
bat out of hell uh it's know this three
foot hover
stabilize and then go it is push roll
the nose over
give it full power and get out of there
as quick as you can and
the first couple times you do it for a
new guy it scares you because you think
you're going to hit the rotor blades on
the ground
you roll it over so far but uh
how much clearance do you have oh you
got your front rotor blades
six or seven feet easy no factor yeah
it's no factor
but when you're sitting there and you're
normally looking at you know it's
sitting up there
15 feet and then all of a sudden it's
six feet off the ground you go okay
scare the crap out of here uh you say
here
dan or he's you're getting advised dan
don't fly without a map
and know where you are at all times on
that map if you go down you're not gonna
have a lot of time to figure that out
this was another cool thing is you guys
were just doing land nav the whole time
yeah no you're not you're not looking at
any kind of instrument to know where you
are i mean i guess other than your
compass
the the you had a db ndb non-directional
beacon
uh there was one in tayden we had one at
lyqae
and i believe there was one up at song
bay and if you had to do an instrument
approach you're going to do a
an ndb approach or a gca approach but
that was it
so you really needed to know where you
were at at all times and have a good
idea where you were
were you were you flying in a small
enough
area that you got to know everything
just
really easily from leica up to 10 in was
probably
uh 80 90 miles from teen in across
along the border was probably another
100 miles and then back down to leica
was probably another 80 miles so that
was about the area you're working in
so you had a bunch of geographical
references there there's that road
there's that mountain there's that
whatever there's the river there's a
bridge uh
in fact the funny thing was three core
the area we flew on was pretty flat
uh the vegetation wise but at tayden
there was a mountain there that looked
like an extinct volcano it wasn't but
it's just this
big tit sticking up and that song bay
was another one sitting there
so if you could see those two you knew
exactly where you were at
and then there's thunder road that went
up the middle uh so you had a pretty
good idea where you were
you were at all times
um you're on a mission you're out there
fast forward a little bit you're still
learning
as we made a pass over the intended
landing point mr leak went into
education mode
okay the smoke tells us almost no wind
so that's not going to be a factor
the trees on the south side look lower
than the north side the units on the
south side as well
so we'll make final approach over the
south side never make your approach the
same
twice in a row if you can help it always
make the approach from a different angle
each time
turning into final at the last minute if
you can you make the approach
you make the approach the same each time
and charlie will
fire your ass up got it got it
yes the the big lz's
uh you had a lot of options where it
came critical
was when you got into a smaller lz or a
hover hole that you're gonna have to
resupply at
if if you came in the same way three
times in a row charlie's probably going
to smoke you on the third time you
always tried to come in a different way
a different angle
you had to keep in mind what's the
lowest approach path i can use
especially if you had a heavy aircraft
where's the wind blowing i want to come
into the wind and i want to come in on
the lowest path
so a lot of times that would dictate
that maybe the final turn
would be the same but you want to come
in from the left side you want to come
in from the right side
if you could you'd come in from into the
you come in with the wind and then do a
pedal turn although that seldom very
happened
so you just did not want to have the
same approach the same path every time
when i was home on leave after my year
there
somebody was using my aircraft went into
a hover hole
the same way three times and the third
time charlie got him
and we lost the aircraft lost the crew
and lost everybody on board
you know what's as you as you mentioned
the weight of the aircraft
one thing that i really got an
appreciation for
and i noticed that you know when i would
get out of helicopters you could see you
know the helicopter would move a little
bit depending on what kind of helicopter
it was
but you know when you drive a car if you
put
500 pounds if you put 200 300 400 pounds
into a car you don't really notice it
you have to put a lot of weight into a
car before you
notice it takes a little longer to break
you know maybe if you're if you throw a
bunch of you know
2 000 pounds of bricks into the back of
your pickup truck
you notice that but the huey you guys
could notice
the weight you know three four hundred
pounds is is is a lot different and you
have to be
it's like you guys were so attuned to
those aircraft
the uh the weight and balance you know
if we were at a hover and there was 300
pounds off to one side
you're going to notice that you noticed
it especially the guys started jumping
out of the aircraft
you'd notice the rocking in it a lot of
times going into an lz for the first
time on a resupply
i would try to take 30 water cans that
gave me a good size
load for that trip it also gave me a
load light enough that i could see how
the aircraft was handling
based on the wind conditions and the
approach uh
there was one time i got into an lz i
only had 10 water cans on that's how bad
that
hover hole was but most of the time 30
water cans was good and then
the only going back the second time you
know if i could take more than 30 water
cans and some ammo we'd throw that on as
well but
you always had to be careful and the
crew chief was really the guy
responsible for this
watching where the weight and balance
was at making sure that they ain't
putting too much weight up forward to
the pilots
keep trying to keep it all back back
center around the
transmission well in the center of the
aircraft
another little section here sort of
about what what life was like over there
for you guys
it was obvious that the rear echelon
lived a lot better than those closest to
the front action
we lived good as aviator certainly much
better than the grunts
but these rear echelon mothers ramps as
we called them were living the life
there was always had been and always
would be
some animosity between those on the
front lines and those in the rear
those in the rear areas enjoyed levels
of comfort only imagined by those on the
front clean
sheets hot chow good boots and movies
were just some of the perks
besides never getting shot at and all
the while bitching how tough they had it
because
of the paper cuts they received history
shows general eisenhower wanted paris to
be an
r r center for the frontline troops just
after it was liberated
a hundred and fifty thousand ramps took
up residence
and he could do nothing to dislodge them
some things never change
and they still haven't changed to this
day
during desert storm i was i was out
there with my battalion and
we're wearing jungle boots we used super
glue the club
closes the holes up on the side to keep
the sand out and it got to the point we
were using duct tape to hold the boots
together because they were
just getting torn apart in the flint and
up shows some rims from the back end and
they've all got brand new desert boots
we never got desert boots the whole time
we were there we were front line
infantry
so it hasn't changed and it never will
change you're always going to have that
argument
a perfect example is you look at the
movie uh
uh what the glory about the 54th
massachusetts
infantry regiment and what was their big
complaint boots
it hasn't changed we're still arguing
about boots in the military
i have i have a leadership consulting
company the name of the leadership
consultant
consulting company is echelon front
and there's a very specific reason why
we have that because we wanted people to
know like
we're we're talking about what
leadership is like
from the front on the front lines not
what it's like
in the rear with the gear that's right
well we used to say nothing's too good
for the infantry
so the infantry gets nothing
uh check
next section is called reality sets in
that evening
this is fast forwarding that evening we
were in our tent discussing that day's
activities
the assistant the assistant maintenance
officer came in looking for a beer
hey john how's it going i asked give me
a beer and i'll tell you how it's going
one of the other pilots opened the
refrigerator and handed him a cold one
we have 13 of our 21 aircraft shot to
[ __ ]
two have got to be evacuated back to the
states they're shot up so bad 251 and
228.
of the remaining 11 we have an estimated
3 000 hours of work ahead of us to get
them into flying condition tomorrow
we'll have a total of six aircraft that
we can put into the air
as i already had two in for periodic
inspections
the first of those shot up today will be
up the day after tomorrow
and that's 7 40 as i only only need 24
hours of maintenance to solve that one
i can tell you that maintenance platoon
is not going to get any sleep for a few
days
i silently thank god i wasn't a
maintenance officer
again just pointing out that the
teamwork that it took to keep these
birds
flying was immense immense immense
teamwork to keep them up
uh it was incumbent upon the pilots to
make sure that we weren't messing the
aircraft up with
with tree strikes on rotor blades or
tail rotor strikes on
on on bushes that that was a bad factor
that happened
not paying attention you bend the skids
on a stump or on a log
or you punch a hole in the bottom of the
aircraft from on a stump
so it was incumbent upon the flight
crews first of all make sure you don't
screw the aircraft up
because the maintenance guys when we got
in situations they had more than enough
work
to keep them busy
another kind of interesting thing here
at this time we had no standardized
markings
on the noses of our aircraft the pilot's
doors had a green triangle with a
lightning bolt through the triangle but
that was all
across the nose of each the aircraft
commanders and crews
generally put their individual pet name
on the nose
iron butterfly green lantern devil's
advocate
and hard luck to name a few we had some
really good we had a really good nose
art
artist sergeant scovell who who
was kept busy some units had a bit more
discipline and had a standard emblem on
the noses of the aircraft which you guys
eventually got the chicken we eventually
got the chicken mike scoville
uh he is now a famous artist in in
southwest america
uh he's out there and he still does
great artwork i've got a couple of his
pieces
and he keeps busy with that but at that
time our unit
had an assortment of nose art and it's
got uh it's got changed
there's a great book that a guy named
john brennan
just published his second one and it's
nose art of aircraft
and it covers all a lot of units that
had nose art on them both of my birds
are in there
um what'd you have on your birds well
the first one had the chicken
and then i had a hard luck so
what was that what was the nose art for
hard luck uh it was the cav patch with
the chicken in the middle of it
got it and then hard luck written across
the top i'll send you a picture of it
that's awesome uh
this is another interesting thing and
this is this is i was gonna bring this
up earlier as you were talking about why
it's so important to have
confidence in the aircraft commander as
lou is bringing us into position
as chalk 6 he asked how much formation
time do you have
just when we got in flight school in a
couple hours the other day i replied
without looking in his direction
don't tell me this is your first combat
assault okay i won't but it is
oh i see it's going to be a long day he
took a breath okay
formation flying here isn't like flight
school
he said as he moved closer to the right
side of choc five
in mother rucker which is where you guys
go to flight school and mother rucker
they wanted
two rotor blade widths between aircraft
here we fly at
one to one half rotor from the other
he was going for the half rotor distance
and my pucker factor was starting to
suck the seat up my ass
i looked back at chalk seven oh [ __ ]
he's going for a
half rotor distance as well lou was
calmly smoking his cigarette
and continuing to lecture while he held
the cyclic
cyclic in his hand index and middle
fingers
the one thing you don't want to do is
over wrap rotor blades
oh trust me that ain't happening okay
you got it he said
i responded i got it and i wished i
hadn't
immediately we started sliding back to a
two rotor blade distance
chalk seven called us hey chalk six did
the new guy just take it
great now the entire formation knew i
had it yeah
and he's [ __ ] in his pants now that
wasn't true but it wasn't far from the
truth
okay let's close it back up and get with
the formation i pulled in some more
power and ease that aircraft forward
good now just hold it there lou said and
i immediately started drifting back
no get back up there yeah formation
flying
to be truthful i didn't like formation
i didn't like it in flight school i
don't even like reading about it
i wanted to be i really wanted to be a
dust off pilot because
dust off pilots didn't fly formation so
that made me happy and then they said no
you're going to
lift me and i went oh hell i'm gonna
have to learn how to fly formations i
hate formations
so it was not easy for me to get in
there with lou
and fly formations but he is such a good
pilot and such a good and
calm instructor and it may be because he
usually drank a six pack in the morning
before he got an aircraft i don't know
but anyway he was really good and
really set me to ease and probably after
about
five hours i could get in there and be
comfortable flying
at one road of blade out and and in the
book i go through about
how he taught me about you know how to
get judge your distance how to judge
where you're going to be
how to keep yourself out of trouble in
lz's and stuff uh
really really a good pilot but yeah that
that half rotor blade
that's that scared the living bejesus
out of me
uh you have a section here fast forward
a little bit
you're talking about it's a good
conversation as you know i
tend to bring things back to leadership
and there's a good conversation you have
about leadership in here and it starts
where you're talking about the
current company commander that you had
at this time yeah and the question is
have you ever seen him in the cockpit or
on the flight line or out of his tent
when you do please
please let us know it'll be a first said
mr toliver
the other seconded that comment how come
i asked the ceo is on his third tour
over here
his first was as an advisor in the early
60s and his second was in 65 as an
aviator
pretty rough assignment he took a couple
hits
in the aircraft and on his body he's
paid his dues he only has another couple
of months in command and then he'll
probably move up to battalion or brigade
staff
he's all right he just doesn't care to
fly anymore responded mr toliver
well what makes a good flight leader i
asked as i open another beer for myself
and others
mr reynolds field that fielded that
question he had been in the unit for
about seven months
and was considering extending but not
for our unit
no one seemed to do that extending your
tour was a rare occasion in vietnam
even in those units that appeared to
have high morale and good leadership
a good flight leader must be a good
pilot
must first be a good pilot and know his
aircraft know what its limitations are
and how far he can stretch them he must
be a good aircraft commander taking care
of his aircraft and his crew
just because we're officers doesn't mean
we can't help the crew take care of the
aircraft
did you notice when captain bullock
landed the first thing he did was leave
the aircraft to his crew
and beat feet to the club for a beer
instead of stay behind and help them
sweep it out and post flight it
no he left that to hess his co-pilot for
today
and the crew self-centered bastard just
because he's an
rlo he thinks he's too good to get his
hands dirty
do you think he helped phil sandbags to
build the bunker not him or any of the
rlos for that matter
jameson stood there that day and
supervised while everyone else
did the digging and stacking
okay reynolds that's enough venting
interjected mr toliver
besides being a good pilot and aircraft
commander a flight leader must plan
coordinate and anticipate the mission
once he gets his brief from the ground
commander he needs to do a recon flight
over the lz or pz
he needs to judge how many aircraft will
fit in and what formation will work so
we're not doing last minute dick dance
like we did today
bullock never did a recon and that's why
we were dick dancing in the kill zone
once he's done re once he's done his
recon he needs to coordinate with the
ground commander on what formation will
be
so they can plan accordingly he needs to
coordinate with the attack helicopters
if it's going to be an
insertion he needs to coordinate with
the aircraft commanders and let us know
what's what and he needs to anticipate
what all can go wrong and have a plan
for that as well be it an aircraft
breaking down before the mission
or ground fire on the lz or pz
yes aircraft commander and leadership
was so important
i found out recently that the commander
that we had before
the current man i talked about in there
was worse
than the current company commander and
the current company commander
he just was not interested in being the
company commander or or
exercising leadership uh leadership in
the unit was from the rlo's it was from
our operations officer and one of the
platoon leaders one of the other platoon
leaders who i mentioned in there
uh did not exercise leadership and very
seldom do you ever see him exercise
leadership
and it was pretty much up to the
operations officer and this one other
platoon leader that
that really took things by the horn they
were the flight leaders
um and really guided us pretty much
that's one of the reasons nobody ever
re-up for the unit
the morale on the unit wasn't that good
at the time it was it was good with the
warrant officers and
and the crew chiefs and stuff but as far
as a unit cohesion goes
it was lacking uh
the you mentioned something in there
about the the flight leaders
if you had a flight leader that was
screwed up
everybody's lives were going to be in
trouble and on this one mission there
that bullock was the flight leader
uh we got a bunch of aircraft shot up
that was march 6.
and i think we went in with something
like seven aircraft
one broke down before we got there the
other six went in and the lz had to go
in two two and two
and the nva were sitting there waiting
for us if we ran it against nva
we were gonna be in trouble vc didn't
worry about them they couldn't shoot for
[ __ ] sorry
but uh they they couldn't hit their
their ass with both hands
but uh the nva knew how to shoot at a
helicopter and they did a good job of
shooting at him but
yeah the leadership was important and it
just was lacking when i first got there
yes that that scenario that that i
skipped over
it's it's real obvious you know when you
look at it you're thinking okay
how long is going to take us to put two
birds at a time multiple lifts in a row
before the enemy goes okay well we'll
wait for them and we'll hit them next
time they come in here
yeah a lot of times they'd let you in on
the first lift and
then the second lift that's when they'd
open up on you or the third lift
usually if it was an extraction you
could expect the third lift coming out
to take fire last position you wanted
was number six
in a six ship lift coming out of a two
ship lz
because you're gonna catch every bit of
it they're just waiting for you if they
could knock an aircraft down
then what happens is they've got a
there's a wrench thrown in everything
everybody's got to come back in you got
to pile on
uh and you better have a plan ready for
if you don't have a plan ready for it
there's a crew
going to get killed yeah even you're
talking about the contingency of hey one
of our aircraft might go down before we
even take off
that's right maintenance problem if you
don't have some kind of contingency
and that's a another thing that we'll
get into but the idea so you have the
aircraft commander
who's obviously in charge of their
singular aircraft but then you've got
the flight lead that's
leading the whole operation that's in
charge of it overall
and that that's the person that has to
account for all these different things
that's right that's right usually he
would go out the flight leader would go
out about an hour before
everybody else and get the coordination
with the ground commander done the
artillery etc
go out and do his recon of the lz uh
make sure he knew what formation was
going to finish make sure the ground
commander
knew what formation he needed to have
his troops in to pick up
and he knew what formation you were
going to drop them off because that
would make a difference
in his ground assault plan so all that
coordination had to get done you had to
have a flight leader that was on his
toes
that to do that kind of stuff initially
when i got there
only the rl's rlos could be flight
leaders
warrant officers we were technical
officers not tactical officers so
warrant officers weren't allowed to be
flight leaders when i first got there
here's a mission that we hadn't talked
about yet what's a sniffer
mission i asked this machine picks up
ammonia which bodies give off in this
heat
in the form of perspiration when the
machine gives off a reading of max
the operator will call our call out max
mark which means he has a large group
giving off a lot of perspiration
and we should engage problem first
problem is
not only do humans give off ammonia
but so do monkeys so we'll probably be
shooting a lot of monkeys second problem
is
in order for this to work we'll be
flying at tree top level at 60 knots
the two cobras and from el lobo will be
1 000 feet and following us and will
engage
if we call for fire or are taking fire
bob and bob informed me
you're [ __ ] me right we're going to
fly at treetop at only 60 knots
i [ __ ] you not bob said with a grin so
that's an interesting one yeah the
sniffer missions were
they were they were interesting uh the
the first time i took a hit in the
aircraft
and we were flying along and the guy ran
out max mark and about that time a
claymore in the top the tree went off
and uh like a shotgun blast hit the
front of the aircraft
so but uh i am sure that more monkeys
died
than nba from the sniffer missions tell
you the truth it was
um now here's something that you
mentioned
uh before fast forward a little bit mike
and i
walked back to the aircraft and saw that
i had
that it had a light load of ammo morning
missions usually meant picking up empty
water and mermite cans from the night
before and taking ammo in for the day
ahead
as we started the aircraft dave asked
have you done any hover holes yet
just around long bean which i understand
isn't much compared to this area i
replied
he says back you're about to experience
the scariest thing about flying in
vietnam
yes yes around so talk to us about talk
to us about hover holes hover holes long
been
uh the vegetation around long bend was
the biggest trees were only about 30
feet
well scattered out you had some brush
and stuff like that so it was
it was pretty open terrain uh you could
find an lz pretty easily
nothing to it up along the cambodian
border
song bay region that we flew in a great
deal there it was different
there it was triple canopy jungle uh the
trees were about 300
feet high and it was packed there was no
lz's
to get an lz you either had a bomb
crater from an air strike
or they would bring in a daisy cutter a
15 000 pound bomb that had chains
welded around the outside the casing
they dropped it from a c-130 on a
parachute
and it had a probe on the end of it and
it would come down when that probe hit
the ground that thing would go off
and it would make a nice one-ship
helicopter lz
it would clean out every tree every
stump everything
just beautiful but most of the time you
didn't get that you got the bomb crater
from a b-52 strike to go down in
and so when you come into that thing
here you are you got a load on board
30 water cans you coming in that thing
you're looking for the wind
you want to land into the wind turn into
the wind and you start down
you're at a hover and you're hovering
down 300 feet
the eyes in the back are the crew chief
and door gunner and they're telling you
bring your tail right bring your tail
left drop down
stop come right come left
start down stop move your tail to the
left
and you worked your way down through
those trees
to get to the bottom that hole there
were times i would look up through the
greenhouse window
and i couldn't see the sky these kids
would wander
make us come down we'd slide around drop
down on the tree limb
slide back down underneath that tree
limb and start back down turn the tail
boom
slide down some more and it takes all
the eyes all
eight eight high balls in that aircraft
to bring that aircraft down into those
holes
are you working with the same air crew
all the time yes
well the only the only person that
wasn't the same would be the the
right seat pilot aircraft commanders
flew left seat
right seat right seat pilots flew the uh
they were the new guys
and we rotated new guys through through
the aircraft commanders but it'd be me
my crew chief my door gunner be always
the same and that's the full loadout
co-pilot pilot co-pilot door gunner and
crew chief
yeah so you know exactly when this guy
says left a little bit
you know what that means yeah in fact uh
they would have to say uh mr jackson
come left your other left so
everyone swallowed i screw up oh okay
uh yeah that sounds freaking scary
um
you're having some uh some chow and
captain bullock
and what's captain bullock's position he
was one of the platoon leaders okay so
he's one of the platoon leaders and he's
got
he's doing some introductions he says
this is lieutenant weed
he said indicating the new pilot
lieutenant weed was tall lanky
with long blonde hair reminding me of a
california surfer which he claimed he
was during
his introduction we didn't pay much
attention until someone asked him for
his first name
richard was his response lou couldn't
let that one go
looking at the four of us he said prob
probably loud enough to be heard by the
group
lieutenant dick weed we couldn't keep it
in all three of us were in hysterics lou
maintained a straight face standing up
and turning to lieutenant dickweed to
introduce himself
welcomes her i'm lou price heading back
to the states in a month
he said and left the mess hall
lieutenant dick weed was in vietnam on
his first tour and he would prove to be
a cocky guy if he wasn't in charge of
something
he tried to make himself in charge and
on one more than one occasion was put in
his place by a flight
leader or an aircraft commander he
arrived the unit before i made aircraft
commander so i was fortunate enough
never have to fly with him
yeah he was one of those lieutenants
that thought because he was a lieutenant
he would be in charge of the aircraft it
it took him a while to realize that no
you don't get to be in charge of the
aircraft until you're voted charge of
the aircraft so
we had many many times with lieutenant
dick weed
uh the night the night hunter killer
missions you already you already kind of
briefed what those were
and that you preferred to be the bait oh
yeah yeah i'd much rather be the bait
uh they they were they were good
missions uh
a lot of times she flew them down the
rivers uh
so you'd be flying along and and one of
the reasons
you liked it because you knew if you had
an engine failure you'd be better off
going into the river than you would into
the jungle so we always flew it right
right along the edge of the tree line
there uh but you'd fly along it was
interesting
uh you were looking for something you
weren't just born a hole in the sky like
the
the cobra and the flareship or you had
the same crew all the time
usually the guys that were on the
searchlight and the starlight scope
that was usually somebody from the
supply room or one of the kids out of
maintenance that wanted to go out and do
something besides his normal job so
they would jump up and volunteer for
that the knight hunter killer mission
that crew got that mission for a month
so when everybody else was out flying in
the daytime we'd be sleeping
and when they came back in that's when
we were going back out so you got to
work with the
usually the same units and you got to
know the the brigade staff at the you
know the second brigade and the areas
that you're working
uh you got a good relationship with them
that that carried over once you're back
on day shift with these guys
did you feel like um
safer because you're flying at night and
it's hard to see a helicopter at night
or was a little bit
a little bit but then again too you know
you know you're out there trying to get
shot at
uh we flew at the pilot's doors open
uh off took those off the aircraft why
is that
because each one of the pilots would
carry an m79 grenade launcher on his lap
check
and we'd fire it out the door if we
needed to so
and you know it was just kind of nice to
be able to look out there i couldn't
couldn't fly the doors off during the
day for some reason but
uh we like flying it at night like that
so and and go
an example there you talked about three
times so you got the so you got the 50
cal in the back you got
what a cobra gun ship as well with all
their munitions but you guys
had to make sure you had those m79
that's right that's right we had a 50 on
one side and 60 on the other and the two
m79s in the laps
the one time we got in trouble and it we
it was one of the cases where
we almost flew the mission three times
the same way
uh we were coming back we've flown twice
up in song bay
on the river threw it the first night
one way flew at the second night the
same way the third night
thought let's change up so we came
around and we flew in the opposite
direction
we're coming down and the cobra
starts screaming at me you're taking
fire and my crew chief he looked behind
us he said yes sir we're taking 51 fire
from behind us
you can tell it's 51 because it looks
like a flaming basketball
coming up at you and the cobra starts to
roll hot and another 51 opens up in
front of me
and then a third 51 opened up on the
other side of the river
and that's the way they would do it
they'd set up 350 once and try to catch
you
in the middle of the cone and they were
set up perfect if i'd been coming from
the other direction
i'd have been right caught between two
of them easily but as
it was one gun was out of position the
flare ship dropped his flares and then
we spotted all three of them
and the cobra went to work and my crew
chief which was our company commander at
that time
uh flying his first night hunter mission
uh he was on the phone
calling the artillery up so the next day
they went out and found what the results
were and and then the mission went to
another unit
i warned them about that they did the
same thing i did
and the third day they got fire
and they were ready with the artillery
and the next day they went out and
picked up pleased up all three guns and
about 21 bodies so
are you getting shot at the 51 cows that
is that green tracer coming at you
yes see that's the weird thing and i've
talked about this with some other guys
in viet
that we're in vietnam is for us
everyone has red tracer now yeah so you
just it's cr
it's it's different we don't have that
distinguishing characteristic of green
traces green tracers and they look like
flaming basketballs at night
in daytime it looked like a bit you know
flaming hardball but
at night that was a basketball coming up
you just oh my god there was no doubt in
your mind
what was shooting at you
a little uh leadership here major
anthony so you get a new a new company
commander
major anthony now the new company
commander just stood there looking over
us and we had him no one said anything
until he finally told us to take our
seats
he then went on to give us his
philosophy on command and how he
expected the unit to operate
an hour an hour later in the club some
discussions took place
about what had been said mike said dan
what did you get out of the major speech
i'm run wondering if i heard wrong
what i heard was don't do anything
that's going to jeopardize my success
and command and will get along fine
do so and i'll be unmerciful upon you
yeah i heard that too mr hess agreed i
continued you know i've seen commanders
like this
when i was a kid with some of my dad's
skippers having a command
is a is a mandatory is mandatory for a
successful career especially the higher
up you go however managing and leading
that command effectively and efficiently
is what's important
some officers view it as a threat if
their subordinates do anything that
would reflect badly on them
major anthony strikes me as that type
we'll just have to wait and see i guess
and he did not prove us wrong uh
he was really afraid that we were going
to ruin his career and his last comments
when he finally gave up command was
well i don't have you guys to ruin my
career anymore so
wonderful i never saw him fly a mish a
combat mission
uh he'd fly the ashen trash going down
the saigon to the px and stuff like that
he moved his tent because we lived in
tents at that time
he moved his tent out to the flight line
and he would sit there in a chair
and when you it was time for you to
launch he'd check your times off
if you launched late you're gonna hear
about it that night when you got back in
but uh he was very very much fearful of
his career and i'm sure that
uh his career puppy ended disastrously
for him i hope
on april 16th 1969 i was flying with mr
driscoll
returning from a long day in quan loy i
say that right yep
in kwan loi area flying resupply of
one of the infantry battalions it was
late in the afternoon the sun was
setting
we were monitoring monitoring the four
radios when we heard the mayday call
mayday mayday lobo one three is going
down
mr driscoll a cobra just went to the
bamboo
at three o'clock said our crew chief
specialist grossman
lobo13 got off one call before he plowed
into the bamboo
he was in a dive on a gun run and pulled
out too late
only being able to get the nose of the
aircraft up but not enough to stop
his downward motion he crashed into 10
foot high bamboo
and put the aircraft over on its side he
was on top of an
nva bunker complex quickly mr driscoll
took controls from me
and told me to plot our location and get
out an additional mayday call which i
did
alerting everyone where we were while i
did that mr driscoll made an approach
into a small clearing he spotted close
to the downed aircraft and landed
it was just big enough for us to fit
into the first thing i noticed
was the nva bunker opening not 10 feet
from my door
i drew my 38 caliber pistol and pointed
at the opening expecting someone to open
fire at any moment
the downed crew was struggling to get
the miniguns off the front of the cobra
when they began taking small arms fire
specialist grossman
opened with the m60 machine gun shooting
at nothing specific
but in the direction of the enemy fire
as did specialist leonard
our door gunner i cocked my 38 and
waited
as soon as the down pilots got the
miniguns off the down cobra
they ran to our aircraft and mr driscoll
pulled power to get us out of there
as both gunners were firing and i
emptied my 38 at the bamboo
worthless weapon the down pilots thanked
us profusely for saving their butts
as they occupied the other side of the
chicken pen
their co came over that night and bought
drinks for us at his club
since we no longer had one he invited
major anthony who declined to drink with
us but made sure we didn't fly the next
day
a few months later i came in from my
flight and lying on my bed were orders
for an air medal with v
the downed aircrew had put in our crew
for the award
there was nothing our ceo could do about
it but instead of presenting the awards
to us in front of the entire company
he simply put them on our beds or at
least had the orderly room clerk do it
he did that as well for the crew chief
and the door gunners awards
the man held grudges his last words to
anyone when he departed the unit after
six months was something to the effect
of
he wouldn't have us around to ruin his
career i think he may have done that on
his own so
his lead his leadership style uh
when he first got there that first night
and
i put this in the book he came into the
club which was our we had a big gp
medium tents where
our club was at and he came in and uh
he asked he says how many who who's
flying tomorrow
well a bunch of the guys raised their
hand he said gentlemen no drinking 24
hours before you fly
and everybody's going wait a minute
we fly every day and that was his point
army of policy was you would not drink
24 hours before you fly
or smoke within 50 feet of the aircraft
well warrant officers to us it meant you
didn't
smoke 24 hours before you flew or drink
within 50 feet of the aircraft
but he didn't go along with that so he
shut the club down
and that way there he could say if
somebody crashed
he could say hey it's my policy they
violated my policy because they drank
the night before
so they couldn't blame him that's the
way he was well
the cobra company commander he invited
us over so we went over there
our company commander wouldn't go he
made sure we didn't fly the next day
but uh but yeah it's just the way that
man was
okay well i'm glad that you had a
horrible leader but damn going into that
lz landing on top of an nva bunker
complex grabbing those guys it must have
been mayhem
well it's you had no choice i mean you
don't leave somebody behind
and that's kind of one of our mottos was
you don't leave people behind you saw
the cobra go down
we didn't know it was a bunker complex
until we got on the ground there with
them
and i look over and i see this opening
there and i've got this worthless
pistol that you couldn't hit a thing
with
and but that's what you do and we did
that many times over is that you go into
some place that
because you had a crew down you go and
you get the crew out
did your aircraft take any hits on that
one no we didn't take any hits on that
one
no uh that's just what you're doing no
time to think about it no no time to
think about it
if you thought about it you would have
never become a helicopter pilot to start
with
you know i had a i had a guy by the name
of dean ladd who was a
marine corps officer in world war ii and
he was going into tarawa ooh and he'd
already been into
a couple other islands i mean he was a
he just
combat combat combat now he's going into
tarawa
and you know there's shelling and
there's machine gun fire
and i asked him i said so when you are
getting out this is as they realize at
tarawa you know
they hit the coral reefs now they got to
walk 800 yards and there's freaking
japanese machine gun fire coming
i said when you know when you when you
realize you're gonna have to walk were
you thinking
uh i might get shot or whatever he's
like nah that wouldn't happen to me no
it'll happen to somebody else
and that's pretty much what everybody
everybody says like it might happen and
he ended up getting shot he ended up
getting gunshot and somehow survived but
the attitude of like well look it's
going to be dangerous for other people
but not for me
i think i think the helicopter parts for
a large extent had that same attitude
you know
hey we hate to see an aircraft go down
it's going to be somebody go down but
it's not going to be me
and you just you just didn't think about
that happening to you
if you did you probably wouldn't have
finished the mission
yeah i was going to say maybe you get a
guy like your earlier company commander
who had deployed already who had done a
tour over there
and he had seen combat take taking hits
to his body and to his aircraft
and eventually he realizes oh this i'm
not quite as good as
maybe you're not as lucky as i think i
am and i'm going to sit back here yeah
and i'm
i'm not invincible so and i can see that
would happen with an older guy like that
but
uh young guys and that's the reason they
have young guys as helicopter pilots and
crew chiefs is that
young guys just don't have any fear
maybe we're not smart enough to have
fear
uh oh yeah
absolutely absolutely
uh fast forward a little bit throughout
the spring and summer of 1969 enemy
forces attacked firebases along the
border their tactics were always the
same waiting until after midnight the
enemy would commence their attack with a
mortar and rocket barrage in concert
with sappers attempting to penetrate the
wire followed by infantry waves
attempting to penetrate the perimeter
lz grant was a favorite target of these
attacks several times between february
and may
lz grant experienced major attacks the
first in february
saw the battalion commander lieutenant
colonel gorvad killed when a round hit
the talk
he was seriously wounded but refused to
leave the battle the enemy managed to
penetrate the perimeter wire
and fighting was fierce to include
artillery lowering the tubes and firing
point blank into the charging enemy with
anti-personnel shot
bluemax gunships were called in and
engaged the follow-on enemy as well
as pursuing those attempting to retreat
in may lz grant was under attack again
simultaneously quan loy lz jaime and lz
phyllis also came underground assaults
that night the enemy wanted the first
cavalry division out of three core
region
which was not going to happen yeah they
they started stepping up the fight back
then
and uh hitting those three lz's at the
same time that that had
everybody up and scrambling we got
pulled out in the middle of the night to
start flying resupply in there
and you had to be careful when you took
the resupply in because you had you're
trying to go in there
but where the nva at around that wire so
you're looking to see where most of the
shooting is at
and you come in most of the time you
come in fast and low
and kick out and just that's the way the
grunts want it they didn't want to have
to run out there to grab ammo or grab
your aircraft
but then as daylight came out then you'd
start going in there and start getting
more of the resupply in
bringing reinforcements in i talked
about we did one night combat assault
that we brought
reinforcements in and we put them about
two clicks out
and they were catching the nva as the
nba were trying to get back to cambodia
but yeah that they started picking up
hitting those firebases pretty hard
fast forward a little bit we had a new
commander arrive in august
who was a major improvement major robert
saunders am i saying that right saunders
he was a leader and we recognized it
almost immediately one of his first
actions was to allow us to hire hooch
maids
previous commanders wouldn't hear of it
so we cleaned our own tents
now we had hooch maids that would come
over from the village and clean out our
rooms
do our laundry and shine our boots in an
effort to raise morale
major saunders director that one hooch
would be turned into an
officer into a club for the enlisted
members of the unit
there wasn't another there wasn't
another empty hooch available so he
directed that the officers
should build our own club we had an
engineer rl rlo pilot and he
drew up a design for the commander's
approval
with a design we then began a scavenger
hunt for building material
and before long we had an officers club
the brigade
the engineer brigade headquarters poured
a concrete floor for us
in return for some flight time for their
projects yeah yeah
the about time sanders got there we
moved out of the gp medium tents
and moved to the other side of the
chicken coop uh or the other side the
chicken pen
and took over some wood buildings
that were hooches and that's when
saunders said okay you can have hooch
maids now
but he said i'll tell you right now
better not be any sex going on with the
hooch mates
and so the guys were they were pretty
adamant about watching that that there
would be no boom boom girls
and uh that that increased morale
significantly right there but then he
said okay
uh there's an empty hooch that's your em
club
officers if you want one you build it
yourself and
we did the engineer officer he drew up
the plans for we started scavenging
and scavenging stuff up i seem to
remember a pallet of
uh of tin coming flying in one day
on the bottom of a helicopter being
delivered but it was a great little club
they had a
we had a stone bar that
in we were located in a rubber tree
plantation
taboo cutting down a rubber tree you
didn't dare cut down a rubber tree
in fact you couldn't even run military
operations in the in the uh
plantations rubber tree plantations so
we built the bar
out of stone and it went from the wall
to a tree in the middle of the club i
mean it was a nice looking bar we got
done with that
you got any pictures of it oh i wish i
did i don't but we had this big tree
growing up through the middle of the
roof
and so we we built our club and it was
sheet metal on the outside
tin roof we had a big cargo parachute
that we requisitioned one day
uh spread out over the top of it for
extra shave we put we got two of those
parachutes we put one over the enlisted
club as well
so the guys could sit outside and enjoy
themselves outside it was a nice club
and we used to have the pilots would be
over there and then
a lot of the other pilots from other
units or the engineer battalion brigade
their headquarters guys would come over
the medevac nurses would come over
so it was a pretty nice little place so
this is what called what do we call the
club
just the club the chicken coop what do
we call it just call it the chicken
house
the chicken house we had a chicken uh
you know our mascot was a rooster
for a dollar you could buy the rooster a
shot of scotch
brewster would not drink beer he dropped
but it would drink scotch he'd drink
scotch
and that was it you'd buy a shot of
scotch for a dollar from uh
sam our bar made and she'd set it down
for him and the rooster would walk over
and
he'd sit there and drink that scotch now
about two of those that rooster couldn't
walk anymore
but it was funny as hell watching that
rooster what was the rooster's name
rooster the
the seals that seal team two during
vietnam had a had a um
monkey that they brought home from
vietnam oh my god and they had it on the
quarter deck and it was like the most
ornery evil monkey the monkey's name
was jocko you read the partner
in our book about the monkey didn't you
what about it oh
one of our pilots peter oh yeah yeah
yeah when he took it in the aircraft
yeah he took him
here go ahead yeah the guy is a he's a
right seat pilot and they had in vietnam
they had these monkeys they were gibbon
monkeys
they're they get pretty damn big well he
bought one of them and it was kind of
small
and he brought it out to the aircraft
thank god i was not the aircraft
commander that day
so the monkey's sitting there and the
monkey's jumping on his seat and he'd
jump over to the aircraft commander's
seat and then he climb up on the first
aid kit behind the
aircraft commander and scurvy on over
first aid kit
troops jump on board going for a combat
assault and they think this is funny
watching the monkey run back and forth
two minutes out cobras roll hot
one minute out the door gunners open up
and when they opened up
that monkey opened up with his bowels
and his fists
all over the pilot all over the aircraft
commander
screaming his head find the aircraft man
who reached up and grabbed him grabbed
him by the neck
and about 200 feet up tossed that monkey
out the window
i don't know if he learned how to
skydive but that monkey was gone but
nobody would go near that crew that day
they stunk so bad
yeah like i said i'm fast forwarded
through a bunch of stuff there's some
stories in here you gotta read
for sure that's one of them
the other one i was thinking that the
monkeys
and i'm not gonna cover it today but the
the guys are calling in that they're
being
attacked they're surrounded and all this
stuff and you guys got over top
and said uh you're surrounded by monkeys
we didn't tell them those monkeys we
didn't we didn't want to we didn't want
to bust the chops it was a brand new
patrol leader it was a alers team out
there so
we just went ahead and okay yeah we
engaged the monkeys and
yeah and they were able to e and e out
of the area so when we got back into
the brigade talk i said hey what what
the report you get on the enemy
situation out there might not quite be
true
jack um
next up ralph was a good aircraft
commander a quiet man he was the
youngest pilot in the outfit as he
joined the army right out of high school
he was not a drinker and spent his
evenings working on college
correspondence courses his mission for
that day was flying cnc
for the division's engineer battalion
commander
the engineer battalion commander wanted
to fly out to where his engineers were
working on various projects in the ao to
see their progress
not unreasonable as they were scattered
all over the ao improving roads building
a school
and supporting projects on the various
firebases
the day started off normal and they were
visiting the various locations however
just after lunch things changed
the colonel wanted to go on a recon of
some areas
ralph agreed to fly those areas and be
and proceeded to fly
between kwon loy and song bay
the colonel was focused on looking for
clearings finally he asked ralph to take
them down and land in one
ralph asked for the frequency and call
sign of the unit in the clearing so he
could contact them prior to landing
especially as he didn't see anyone in
the clearing the colonel came up with an
excuse
for why he couldn't provide the
information and told ralph just to land
ralph insisted on a call signing
frequency before he'd take the aircraft
down
the colonel became irate but when he
accused ralph of being a coward
that was when things exploded ralph
reached up and disconnected his helmet
from the intercom system
took the controls from the co-pilot and
headed back to camp goat
uh gorvad the colonel was livid
ralph didn't care didn't care reaching
camp corvad am i saying his name was
that's named after the command commander
that was killed during that assault
ralph landed at the engineering pad and
told the colonel politely but firmly to
get out of his aircraft
he then called our battalion
headquarters on the radio which was
being monitored by almost every pilot
from the battalion and told them that he
had just
tossed the tossed engineer 6 out of his
aircraft
and was returning to base to say the
least [ __ ] was about to hit the fan
making that call on the radio alerted
every aircraft on the frequency as to
what had happened
however someone saw ralph's position in
this and nothing came of it
at least on for ralph
yeah you talk about egos and the
engineer had an ego
and he was out to make himself a name
for himself in the division he was a
fairly new guy
and he would do that he tried to get an
aircraft to go down at a clearing
without anybody being in the clearing to
protect them
uh ralph's was smart enough to to say no
calling ralph a coward bad mistake ralph
had already had a silver star at this
point
and a distinguished flying cross
this engineer battalion commander did
that to my roommate
and my roommate flew into the clearing
they never came out
the nva were waiting for him and
everybody was killed
so ralph did absolutely the right thing
with this guy because of his ego
wanting to impress everybody
that you talk about that here exactly
what happened when i
this is fast forward a little bit when i
returned from my mission that evening
major saunders approached my aircraft
as i was shutting down mr corey a word
please
he said as posey opened my door the
major was standing in front of my
aircraft and hadn't approached me yes
sir i unstrapped climbed out and came
over to him
it's mr corey now and said to dan what
did i do wrong
let's walk mr cooper he called over his
shoulder addressing my co-pilot sir
would you grab dan's gear and put it
put in his room please yes sir he called
back with a question to look on his face
we walked halfway back to the chicken
coop with nothing said between us
but were angling towards his hooch
finally he said dan
i have some bad news dave and y.a were
shot down today
i'm afraid the entire crew was killed
y.a was dave's co-pilot for the day and
fairly new to the unit
i felt like i had just been gut punched
what happened sir
as best as anyone could tell while
supposedly flying from quan lloyd to boo
dopp
the engineer colonel had again gone on a
recon and convinced dave to land in a
clearing
a scout team happened to find the
aircraft sitting there it was obvious
that someone had landed the aircraft
before the enemy opened fire with some
heavy weapons
as the only damage to the aircraft was
in the cockpit and transmission
and none in the engine or belly the
skids indicated a
normal landing dave and y.a were still
strapped in their seats
and sergeant alfred the door gunner was
in his as well the crew chief however
was found about a hundred yards from the
downed aircraft it appeared that
specialist collins fought
as emptied as empty 556 shell casings
were around him
but not a weapon the aircraft was
booby-trapped the colonel and his staff
were dead in the back of it there had
been no friendly soldiers at the
location
damn that son of a [ __ ] has gotten more
aircraft shot up than anyone damn his
sorry ass
and now he's gotten people killed at
least as sorry ass was one of them
bastard major sanders just let me rant
while he opened a cabinet and pulled out
a bottle of johnny walker scotch
filling two class glasses he handed one
to me and raised his own
to absent comrades to dave y.a
alfred and collins a few days later i
was sitting in my room writing a letter
when my new roommate owie richie came in
from flying
he looked troubled as he grabbed a beer
and tossed his flight gear on the bed
what's up richie i asked just a bad day
saw my first crash and it was not pretty
he said finishing off the first beer
and opening the second what happened was
it one of ours i asked no it was a
charlie company bird
and one of the pilots was in my fight
class
i just been talking to him before we
launched and now him and his crew are
dead
hid a tree damn were you under fire no
we were coming out of an
lz which we had been in four times
already and the blade on the right side
hit a tree at about 75 feet
rotor blade just came apart and they
crashed and burned no one got out
damn sorry owen who are the pilots let's
see warren officer
thomas brown was in flight school with
me warrant officer dennis varney was the
ac
specialist marcin shelby was the door
gunner
and the crew chief was specialist robert
lazarus
i just met them not an hour before when
i went over to talk to tom
opening another beer for myself i raised
it and tapped richie's beer
in a toast to absent comrades
a few nights later our platoon leader
came walking down the hall the ceo wants
to see everyone in the club he said
we all started heading that way the co
did not look happy
gentlemen take a seat after you get a
beer he didn't have to say that twice
after everyone was seated and holding a
cold one the major raised his beer
to absent comrades the look of shock and
dread was on everyone's face
we all stood and raised our drinks to
absent comrades
we all repeated and chugged our beers
still wondering who'd we lost
motioning us to sit down the major
looked over everyone before he started
to speak
charlie company lost a crew last night
they were on a night mission out of
lz buttons and ran into bad weather at
about zero 200 hours
they attempted to take off in the fog
the grunts on the perimeter said they
had all their lights on so they could
see them
in the soup the aircraft got to about
200 feet
and then it crossed the perimeter wire
it as it crossed the perimeter riot wire
it appeared to roll 90 degrees and
crashed into the trees on the perimeter
the whole crew was lost yeah that that
period of time we started losing crews
and we knew a lot of the crews in the
other units because we flew a lot
together
a lot of times they'd have maybe a unit
could put four birds up for a lift
and you'd get tagged to put two of your
birds with them so you got to know the
other crews and the other pilots as well
but this period of time when saunders
got there that's when we started losing
a lot of birds
and it kept right on up for the rest of
the time i was there
the night birds the huey had minimum
minimum instruments for weather flying
and if the guys didn't practice their
weather flying
they were rusty at it and tried to pull
off in the fog
that sounds like what happened there he
just wasn't on his instruments that
tight and
he lost control of the aircraft hitting
a tree
that happened frequently in fact my last
mission one of my last missions one of
our birds hit a tree
at about 75 feet up and and we got one
guy out
we didn't think he would make it but uh
last summer i had lunch with him at the
congressional golf club in washington dc
and
he pulled through he's in a coma for six
weeks but uh
he looks good he he said from the from
nick down he said i'm one big scar but
from the face up he looked
john looked pretty good so
and the the thing is and i think a lot
of times
people don't understand i mean when this
stuff is happening the war goes on
oh yeah it's like okay we still have a
mission to do
we're still going to get the birds spun
up we're still going to go out and do
our job
yeah yeah you still you got to put it
behind you
at that time i don't know how it was in
other units but at that time in our unit
we never did have a memorial service
when somebody was lost
the just before i left we had a guy that
we all loved dearly a crew chief
and we were on a combat assault and he
got shot in the armpit
well the chicken plate didn't cover the
armpit and he died we had a memorial
service for him
but anybody else we lost the memorial
service was get drunk in the club that
night
so a lot of us just didn't have any
any good thoughts about when we left
there so it was
it was good to see good good to have a a
drunk fest anyway with the guys
fast forward a little bit my crew and i
arrived at the aircraft and conducted
our pre-flight good morning posey how's
she look i asked my crew chief
all goods missed all good mr c he
answered as he closed the engine cowling
quilling how's the guns in ammo i asked
my gunner fresh cans ammo this morning
mr curry we're good
mr corey we're good he responded i
climbed up and looked over the rotor
head while my co-pilot for the day
warrant officer ron fender did the walk
around inspection and tail rotor
all appeared to be good we strapped in
started the engine and waited
ready ready to assume the mission if
called upon
hey one niner two seven is down assume
his mission and contact badger six when
you reach quan loy for further
instructions
flight operator instructed roger three
india one niner has it
i started pulling power oh god okay guys
coming out about this time i saw chip
rumble
chicken man two seven along with his
co-pilot warren officer mccartney
waving to me and running over i set the
aircraft back down
jumping on the skid next to my door chip
asked hey dan i'm
i'm low time pilot for the month let me
take the mission he had just returned
from a seven-day r r trip to hawaii and
hadn't flown much for the past month
you got it i said as ron and i
unstrapped and and climbed out
turning over the aircraft aircraft to
chip and mccartney
we watched as they hovered out of the
chicken pen and onto the runway
we were walking back to flight
operations when they started down the
runway and disappeared behind the trees
reaching flight operations we went in
first class
sergeant first class robinson was crying
he saw us and immediately got a shocked
look on his face
oh my god who's flying your aircraft he
asked i told him why what's the problem
they got off the runway and were
climbing out when the rotor head came
off
they're all dead yeah i was stunned and
suddenly sick to my stomach
outside i threw up ron dropped through
his knees and start and stared at the
ground i went back to my room and just
sat on my bed 30 minutes later
major saunders stock stopped by you okay
danny asked i don't know sir i checked
that head and it all looked good
what happened i don't know but the
accident investigation board will figure
it out you just take it easy
he left but about an hour later he was
back dan i hate to ask you
but can you take a mission it seems
lieutenant weed is too upset to fly his
mission
and has brought back his aircraft
lieutenant weed was close to chip
the aircraft commander yes sir i got it
i picked up my gear
i'll walk out with you i want you to see
i want to see just how upset he is
the major and i walked together to the
flight line we didn't say much as there
wasn't a lot to say i didn't expect what
came at me
as soon as lieutenant weed saw me he
threw his helmet on the ground and came
at me
you son of a [ __ ] corey this is your
damn fault
major saunders step between us
lieutenant stop right there get your
[ __ ] and go to your room
not another word do you hear me now go
turning to me the ceo said dan forget
this
and get on with the mission this wasn't
over however that night
at the club lieutenant weed proceeded to
loudly bow mouth me
i let it go as he was a lieutenant and i
was just a warrant but i finally had
enough hey lieutenant dickweed with all
due respect for your rank go to hell
i knew using his full name as modified
by the warren officers would piss him
off and it did
with that he was up and headed straight
for me i was off my bar stool and eager
to get it on with him
looking forward to hurting him i was not
a brawler but could hold my own in a
fight
just before he got to me captain
armstrong a platoon leader stepped
behind him
and jerked him off his feet don't you
dare move lieutenant captain armstrong
was an infantry officer of considerable
size very tall and very muscular
he was a no-nonsense man mr corey i
think you should retire for the night
now
he told me yes sir and i departed back
to my room in the warren officer's hooch
after any aircraft accident
an accident investigation is held my
co-pilot was interviewed as were the
assistant maintenance officer
and myself the crash site was well was
examined as well
the rotor head was flown to a general
aviation support facility
at vung ii and examined the results were
posted and indicated that the rotor head
had not come off
but it failed the rotor head that had
been put on the aircraft the night
before was a rebuilt one
during the rebuilding the bolt holes for
the bolts that held the pitch change
horn
had been cleaned and resized one
millimeter
however the same original bolt sizes
were installed upon the usns
corpus christi a floating aircraft
overhaul facility
those original bolts were one millimeter
too small
between the test flight and the takeoff
the bolts holding pitch change horn
had failed due to the stress and the
result was a loss of control over the
blades making the aircraft unstable in
flight
the investigation board found that there
was no way to the assistant maintenance
officer
or i could have found the problem as the
bolts hadn't twisted
out but it's simply and instantly torn
out
the bolts were never found but the
condition of the bolt holes told the
story
easy for them to say but this would
haunt me every day i couldn't help but
think
that it was something i should have
caught on the pre-flight
it could have been me and my co-co-pilot
we had come that close
yeah that haunt that that incident has
haunted me for a long time
uh i lost posey i lost quinn
and it was that close that uh
that we almost bought the farm the
maintenance officer had flown the bird
the night before
after they put the rotor head on it and
all seemed well and then we got out
there in the morning and looked
at it and i did the rotor head
the safety wires were all in place the
slippage marks were all lined up and
everything looked good
and but when chip went out he pulled
full power
when he came off the end of the runway
and those four bolts that hold that
pitch change horn on
uh they just blew out and
they said when they maintenance officer
told me he said when we took it down the
wrong town they looked in there they
could see where
the threads had just been ripped apart
they hadn't
they hadn't been screwed out they just
where the bolts exploded out of there so
we lost the crew lost the aircraft
talk about some other missions that you
did you talk about doing some psyops
missions
which yeah they didn't like me to do
psyops missions
why why is that well i did that one
sciops mission
and you know it was just after david
died it was just after
uh chip mccartney was killed and they
say okay you're gonna go out there and
fly this slash mission okay so they put
these big loud speakers in the side of
the aircraft
and this vietnamese captain jumps in and
they say okay we want you to go out this
crossroads
so we fly to this crossroads we're at 2
500 feet and we're flying around this
guy's in the back of the aircraft you
know
sing-song vietnamese language for true
hoys right yeah for two hoys
keep trying to get the the north
vietnamese to surrender
so my crew chief love lace at that time
he looks down he says hey
mr corey there's a bunch of guys down
here in the in the bamboo they're
digging trenches
right alongside the intersection i said
yeah so i look over there i thought well
[ __ ] there they are
nva down there and
i turned to the american the sergeant
and i said hey yeah you think those guys
can hear from
us being up here 2500 feet wouldn't you
like us to go down a little lower
he goes mr corey nobody will fly 1500
1500 is ideal i said yeah i'll take you
to 1500.
so as i'm lowering the aircraft down to
1500 flying this orbit around these
north vietnamese guys now
i turn to my copies and get songbay
artillery on the line he calls up song
bay ardy and says fire mission standby
gives them the coordinates everything we
get down there sure enough
nva starts shooting up at us so i said
we're taking fire and he says
he said yeah we are mr bridges you need
to go back up i said no we need to get a
little further out
so i've just moved out a little bit
further at least kept shooting well
that's what i call the artillery in on
them
and the vietnamese captain in the back
he just went ballistic i mean you know
they're supposed to surrender and i said
well if he talks adam now they're going
to be more willing to surrender after we
hit him with some artillery
we did we put about 12 rounds in there
on top of these guys
and after that the vietnamese guy didn't
want to argue with anymore but
he took us back in the american captain
in charge of the sobs program he came up
he says
we're going to have to crash scratch
this mission off as a failure and i said
well yeah
i said hey you know they started
shooting first and i was protecting my
crew and your crew as well so he's
he just kind of laughed at me and he
tapped me on the shoulder he says yeah i
got it
i understand i hated saps missions
uh this was crazy
your dad was still in the navy at this
time
yeah and he's now an officer and he's in
freaking saigon
yeah yeah he was living well he was one
of the reps he was one of the ramps in
saigon
well deserved i mean after he fought
world war ii and was on submarines i got
no
real problem with him enjoying some time
in saigon so i went and asked the
company commander i said hey sir
this is sanders still i said uh and he
was
sanders getting cords at the end of his
tour so i said hey my dad's in saigon uh
can could he come up and fly three days
with me or something like that and i
thought sanders would say you know
hell no but he said sure bring him up
okay we'll bring
him up so dad came up and i i picked him
up in saigon he jumped in the front seat
before you get there when you're in
saigon i know you went to uh officers
club
with him oh yeah and they they come to
kick you out well as you're going into
the officers club
you see like a bunch of nice pistols
hanging up on the wall
and you're thinking yeah unscared no
one's watching them and you're thinking
well that doesn't seem very smart
so then you sit down having some lunch
with your dad they kicked us out they
kick you out
because you're not a field grade officer
which is a a
major lieutenant commander above so they
kick you out on your way out
some of those weapons went with you
[Laughter]
so you end up with a nice instead of
that 38 caliber pistol that wasn't very
effective you end up with a 45 a nice
1911 i'm sure no
not that's not quite this the right way
let's just say that when i got back to
light k i had a brand new 45
okay so so your dad
ends up freaking coming up how old your
dad at this point
uh dad's probably in about 43
44. he's in the game oh yeah he's in the
game
i think he was he was about 50 when he
retired from the navy and this was
three years before he retired from the
navy so he's in his late 40s okay
uh so he came up and uh what was he
doing what was he some kind of a liaison
or something no no he was
uh in j6 at mcv headquarters
communications
and uh i guess i can say it now it's not
classified anymore but he was working on
the communications plan for the
repatriation of pows
got it is is what he was doing at the
time so uh so he came up to like
a and uh spent about three days with it
flew as my
crew chief or no he's my door gunner
gave my my crew chief
some time off but he did good he he had
have his ass chewed a little bit yeah so
so tell us about the first gunfight
again that's a good one yeah we're
flying along there and uh
he's we're working the lz's and and he's
doing good clearing this in clearing us
out stuff like that so we got the troops
on board
troops all get on the aircraft and dad's
uniform is the same as ours
fatigues and he had his major
his lieutenant commander's leaf on you
which is just a little smaller than the
the army major leaf the grunts are back
there in the back and
all of a sudden somebody starts pulling
on my collar i looked over this this
grunt's pulling he goes hey sir what's
your rank
i said i'm at w-2 why and he goes damn
did that major back there screw up since
he's your door gunner
so i told him no it's my dad he's flying
with us so they thought that was pretty
cool so we go in on this combat assault
we were in chalk five or six position
and uh we're going in in a staggered
right
formation so you got one aircraft in
front of you and you got one off to the
side
six minutes out the artillery goes in
the artillery cuts off at two minutes
out the cobras roll hot
one minute out door gunners open fire
and right away we start seeing green
tracers
and i hear my crew chief's gun firing
but i don't hear my dads
and i said dad open fire nothing
and i'm thinking oh [ __ ] he's been hit
and i turn over my shoulder and look
he's standing on the skids he's got his
monkey harness on
and he's taking pictures out in front
i got on that ra i got on the intercom i
said dad get your ass in here and get on
a goddamn
gun so he gets on the gun when we got
back
uh we had a discussion about crew chief
dude
he's a door gunner on the aircraft and
he wrote my mother and he said you know
i've had a lot of ass tunes in my navy
career but that's the worst one i've
ever had
and he took it i would give him credit
he took it uh
quite well and uh he came back and flew
us about three or four times that's
crazy
uh i i like this this conversation you
had with your dad it says uh
he says i noticed one thing different
about those air force pilots from you
guys
air force pilots seem to be outgoing and
always in a positive mood
versus you guys who always seem
withdrawn and pensive he explained
and then you replied dad an air force
pilot is that way because he's flying a
machine that wants to fly
and if left alone will generally fly
quite well on its own
in addition compared to a helicopter an
airplane has very few moving parts that
can cause a serious malfunction
on the other hand helicopter pilots fly
a machine that does not want to fly
and only does and only does so by the
interactions of the pilot to balance
four forces all opposed to each other
plus a
helicopter has a lot of moving parts any
of which
breaking can and does cause a major
disaster
helicopter pilots are moody because we
know something is going to break if it
hasn't done so already
that's right that gave the old man
something to think about yeah dad had
flown with
uh one of the things he did when he came
up there to like hey we had a
uh ov10 squadron that flew out of there
the broncos
and we got him a ride in one and he went
out and flew at them he flew with a
captain rider an australian captain it
was an exchange officer
and he thought that was pretty cool out
there flying with those guys and
so when he came back in that night
that's when this this conversation came
up about you know
the the fighter pilots they're just
jovial and happy and cetera and you guys
you're all kind of
moody and down in the dumps and they
said yeah and that's why you know we fly
something that doesn't want to fly
harry reisner about 1973
wrote a great article about uh
helicopter pilots
and helicopters and it's it's kind along
that same line is what uh
what dad night's conversation was yeah
well it's
like you said a a a plane you can
you can let go of the stick and it'll
kind of just cruise for a while
yeah it'll fly itself but a helicopter
is not that's not happening no that's
not happening
that's not happening uh they have now
uh helicopters that do have an autopilot
on them but
in those days you let go of those
controls in the huey
yeah no telling where she's going to go
uh fast forward a little bit you get you
eventually
get orders and you're going to go to
fort ord which to you sounds great
because it's up by monterey and you
start like thinking oh i'm going to
california i'm going to be
yeah but it's going to be awesome and
then you start asking people about what
the deal is and you start hearing that
it's actually horrible to be there it's
expensive as hell
and the high school kids are driving
around in jags and mercedes and
and you're gonna barely scrape by
won't be able to afford anything as a
warrant officer
and so you figure out okay i'm gonna try
and get my orders changed
and you go talk to your ceo
and and you say hey can i get my my
order's changed he's like no i can't do
you think you think i'm magic and then
he says now wait one there is a way you
can change your orders
now i was excited there is how you can
extend for six months and stay in nam
he was grinning did he have something to
do with my rfo i wondered
sir you're kidding hell i've already had
my cherry busted had a door gunner
wounded
had hydraulic failure and a compressor
stall add to that um over 1300 hours of
flying here
i didn't mention the aircraft had gone
down with the pitch change horn failure
the one i'd almost ridden in
he knew that was on the scorecard
without me mentioning it
yeah you've racked up some time but
that's only but that's the only choice
you have think about it
and he headed to the bar yes yeah
and i really thought at the time i
thought well hey he can just change my
order it's not a problem but
no it wasn't but him and the and the
platoon leader lieutenant beauchamp or
captain beauchamp
they had probably already worked this
out ahead of time i'm thinking they
didn't have anything to do with me
getting orders to ord
but putting the idea in my head to
extend and
up to this time we had not had guys
extending
at least for our unit and so when i said
okay yeah i'll extend i'm thinking
i'll go to a medevac unit which is what
you kind of wanted to do yeah because
you don't have to fly in formation yeah
so because i didn't have to find
formation but uh
then boat champion so so they so they
get you to extend yeah they get you
they say listen yeah you don't go to
medevac unit it'll be in the rear with
the gear you know and you'll just have
to fly
and you'll be nurses there and the whole
nine yards so you agree
it seems like a good idea you're not
going to get it or you can go back to
some place
once you get orders you'll go back to
some place better than ored
and so you get that extension yep and
then and then then you guys
go out you do some drinking and and now
you guys are drinking hard i'm gonna go
to the book after about an hour of this
the company about an hour about people
feeding you drinks
the company clerk came up to me in the
office club and asked me to sign some
papers what's this for i asked with
a slight slur and blurry eyes i was
becoming as drunk as our rooster
who frequented the club each night was
fed scots a damn rooster would not drink
beer expensive taste
oh it's just some paperwork i need your
signature for on the extension
he said and i signed it without another
thought i thought i had submitted
everything
as he left the rlo's excuse themselves
slapping each other on the back and
laughing their asses off
two nights later i found out what was so
funny the major wanted all the pilots in
the club for a meeting
and then he goes in there and he
announces that uh
i'm happy to announce one of our
chickens has decided to stay in the coop
mr corey has graciously modified his
extension to remain with
us instead of going to a medevac unit
thank you dan
that's what happened oh yeah they got
you drunk and you signed papers to
stay on i did and then uh right after
that he announced well
who's the new instructor pilot and one
of the pilots asked him that and he just
kind of grinned and he looked around he
goes
mr corey's the new instructor pilot so
tell us about the instructor duties yeah
the instructor duties yuri the unit
instructor pilot
and your job was to when a new pilot
showed up in the unit
they flew with you their first
orientation flight would be with you
and then frequently they would fly with
you then well major decided that
since i was going to take my extension
leave in about a month and a half
he wanted me to fly with new pilots only
so a pilot new pilot would come in and
we had two come in right away almost
mr i forget the one gentleman's name the
other one was dumas
but i would fly with one on one day and
fly with the other one the other day and
vice versa
the days they weren't flying with me
they'd be flying with another ac
but it was my job to teach them combat
flying combat auto rotations combat
takeoffs how to get in a hover hole
uh those sorts of things and you're
still doing your normal missions oh yeah
we're still having to fly with the new
guys yeah
yeah you just you fly the normal
missions just now you got
really new guys flying with your right
seat
on may 4th 1969 two aircraft from our
sister company company b
joined a formation with a second
aircraft in a right echelon
to the first the second aircraft
attempted to pass the first aircraft on
his right side there was a
miscommunication between the two
aircraft resulting in a mid-air
collision
all crew members on both aircraft were
killed yeah
yeah when you flew formation you flew it
by sop
but if but if you were going to do
something outside of the the normal
formation flying
like trying to pass somebody on the
opposite side you had to be sure and
communicate with them
so that everybody understand what you're
going to do and evidently there was a
lack of communications with these two
guys and
one flew right into the other
you know you had to worry about getting
shot at you had to worry about the
aircraft
maintenance failure and you had to worry
about somebody flying into you
yeah i was telling you earlier that
pilot was never really my kind of thing
like i have no desire to be a pilot
that's one that's
like couple the reasons right there i
don't like relying on some big big
machine with a bunch of parts that i
don't understand that's gonna keep me
alive and keep my friends alive i don't
like that
it was just a matter of trusting each
other you know i trusted
100 percent the guys in our unit that i
flew with
90 the guys in other units i didn't fly
with
so but you had that trust and bond built
up amongst you you know you all went to
the same flight school
you all understood about what what the
different formations were
and so you didn't do anything radical
and even when we would fly you know our
company would fly out their company
because we all flew by an sop
we had a system we understood the system
and so things were relatively safe it's
when somebody would go do something like
this
that's out of the ordinary that that
people got killed
yeah and this is because everyone's
relying on each other so much i mean
it's similar in the seal teams if
somebody
if somebody's outside
it's if if the job is outside their
capability like
it's a non-starter that's why i like
what i like what you guys had with the
with the ac in order to be an
aircraft commander you had to get the
thumbs up from the other acs
there's a standard there that you can't
compromise because it's truly putting
everyone else at risk that's right
everybody
fast forward a little bit coming around
the end of the valley i climbed up the
ridge and popped up looking
south right down the runway this is just
out on another freaking mission which
you're doing all the time there's a
sniffer mission
on the on the left specialist linman
started shooting
the sniffer team let loose with a 40
millimeter round un
under the bamboo canopy on the edge of
the runway was a regular village of nva
soldiers lying around some were in
uniform
some lying in hammocks some cooking chao
tables were made out of bamboo as were
chairs they were totally surprised
as were we and this is they're they're
occupying an
abandoned air fuel yeah so that's why
you see an airfield and there's
the nva right there lobo on my left in
the bamboo fire i screamed as i
increased power and air speed rapidly
staying low to the ground
i had never seen so many enemy soldiers
before as soon as i spoke
2.75 inch rockets were slamming into the
bamboo and
as nva troops ran and dove for cover
lobo was firing ripple effect
automatically launching 28 rockets with
just one pull the trigger
and punching the target then his minigun
opened on the tree line on my left
as we were hauling ass down the runway
as we cleared the abandoned sf camp and
runway we stayed low level until we were
confident we could climb to altitude and
not get hit
by a 51 cal machine gun but something
wasn't right
and in the feel of the aircraft the
cyclic felt stiff and was getting
stiffer
mr corey we have a problem the housing
for the push-pull tube is shot away and
each time you move the
cyclic control it's binding the rods can
you fix it i was surprised at how calm i
sounded
when i was [ __ ] bricks here no sir i
could hold up the tubes but then i would
be flying the aircraft from here he said
well what do you suggest slowly descend
and find a clear area that we can do a
running landing into
you might be able to raise the nose but
it'll be a one-time move
not to be countered by attempting to
lower the nose okay i can do this
running landings were practiced and the
further south i flew the better terrain
for this
a runway would be nice but the closest
was song bay
and it was laid out east to west where
as i was flying north to south
that ain't going to work guys start
looking for an open area what about the
road
bruce said he was now on his third
cigarette since i had taken the controls
damn he better save a couple for me i
thought in the distance we could see a
straight stretch but the trees were
close and the sides were lined with
bamboo
it's gonna have to do i want everyone up
forward and seat belts on
linman make sure everyone is strapped in
tight as i got to treetop level with the
road
under the chin bubble i started easing
up on the i started easing the nose up
slowly the air speed began to bleed off
80 knots 70 knots 60 knots
and our speed continued to drop we were
slapping the tops of bamboo stocks now
20 knots bamboo stocks were breaking off
and i could feel the main
rotor buffeting as we hit thicker
vegetation i just didn't want to know
what kind of vegetation at this point
just don't let us hit a hardwood tree
trunk and rip the rotor head off
at 20 knots the skids touch the ground
and we're sliding along
steering with the pedals to maintain a
straight line broken bamboo was whirling
about as if it was in a tornado
as the aircraft came to a stop i was
shutting the engine down while linman
and dietrich
had the guns in hand with belts of ammo
in their arms
and and we were on asking the aircraft
as mike landed right behind me
he didn't worry about tree limbs one
look at my rotor blades told him
that i'd cleared out everything for him
as if a giant lawnmower
had passed over the bamboo field as mike
flew
us back to song bay dietrich had asked
the question that i knew was coming
hey mr sinky was that your first time
shot down bruce walked into it yeah i've
only been in country a couple months
thank you sir you're buying the beer
tonight i considered it
i considered if i should speak up as
well as it was my first
then mike spoke up hey mr corey that's
your first two isn't it
there'll be lots of free beer tonight
guys i started a protest
but to no avail yep yep yep yep they
took uh
we took one round and it's all it hit us
but it hit right on the housing for the
the push pull tube for the for the
cyclic so
every time i move that psychic i can
feel it starting to bind up i didn't
dare
try to move it left or right because i
you know i did not want the aircraft in
a turn
and it just so i just kept moving it
forward and back and
finally we just found a straight stretch
of road and said okay let's
let's go down the road and we practice
running landings all the time so
that was no big deal i was just worried
that i wasn't going to get that nose far
enough back
up to slow the aircraft down now last
thing i wanted was be doing
60 knots sliding down that road on my
skids
so making sure we had enough room to
ease that nose
up and keep that aircraft from sliding
too fast but
yeah mike mike saw us go down he heard
the mayday lobo put out a mayday for me
as well
and uh they got in four hours later
schnook came in picked the aircraft up
and
flew it back to lykay and yeah that's
what's crazy you these
helicopters you get shot down and you
just leave the bird
and then a ch 40 47 would come in
strap on to the thing and take it home
well what would happen is that a bird
would go down
and first of the ninth calf they always
had a rapid reaction force let's call
their blues
and they would fly in that rapid
reaction force into where the aircraft
was if it was salvageable
set security yeah set security and then
they'd hook the aircraft up to a ch-47
and 47 would pull the aircraft out and
fly it back to its own base
and that's all they did with this one
they replaced the rotor blades they
replaced the bell housing on the bottom
and that was it
two days later that bird was back up and
flying again
now when you did do you get that do you
stay in your own bird
like all the time are you always flying
the same bird yes unless it's down for
maintenance for some reason so
did you get some other random bird are
all the birds a little bit different now
they're pretty much laid out the same i
mean
there were little corpse about them but
nothing that you'd really notice
we had we had uh outboard motors
right for our zodiac boats yeah and they
even though they're all from the same
company they're all supposed to like we
had names for them
you know and they would all be just a
little bit different
temperamental temperamental like there's
one i remember it's called frankenstein
it was like the one that was
it was all it looked like it would never
run but it was the most reliable
but you but it's but for you you didn't
care
if you got a different bird other than
hard luck yeah yeah i didn't care we'd
fly anything
uh what you didn't like though is you
got a different crew chief
you always got a different crew chief
and a different gunner because the crew
chief and gunner always stayed with
their aircraft
if the aircraft was now for maintenance
they were down for maintenance as well
helping
help get the aircraft ready so that's
the only thing i didn't like about is i
had to
learn different crew chiefs and
different gunners but uh otherwise yeah
it's the aircraft were pretty much the
same
are you so you're flying this is analog
flying
right i mean this is you're moving the
stick and it's moving a piece of
uh whatever cable that's moving
something it's moving a tube
it's moving a tube but that's what it is
so this
are is a blackhawk the same thing is a
hawk
is it is it analog like that where
you're actually moving
a a gear somewhere or moving a cable or
moving a tube
i think so i'm not sure about the
blackhawk uh but on the huey
it was always tubes the only place you
had cables
was back in the back and the tail boom
and that was a cable two cables
two or four i can't remember i think it
was two cables that ran
down the tail boom back to the tail
rotor but for the for the cyclic the
collective
uh and the pedals initially those were
all push pull tubes they were called but
it's all mechanical it's all mechanical
it's all mechanical there's no
there's is there anything like uh power
steering
uh the only thing that was at was the
governor the fuel on the
the huey that was controlled the
throttle was controlled by a governor
so once you started the aircraft up you
brought the throttle up all the way
and the governor would stop it at uh
6600 rpm on the engine
and you had a governor control switch if
that went out
then you had to fly the aircraft
manually and
you learned how to fly it manually with
the th55 in flight school
but on the huey that was really
sensitive
with that trying to fly that thing with
the the manual control on the throttle
but that's the only thing that was
automatic so to speak on the hue it was
that throttle control
man these are some like durable
beasts oh they were the huey the cobra
gun ship
uh the old charlie model gunships they
were just great i mean
bell helicopter built a great aircraft
force
and it did well the uh
hughes built the oh6 which you you see
those with the mh6s now
in in task force 160. the the oh-6
guys love to fly that thing because if
it got shot down
uh it would crash the rotor had come off
the tailbone come off and it rolled like
an egg
and so guys really they they didn't mind
well they didn't mind getting shot down
and crashing but
their survivability rate was really good
in the oh six
all right um going back to the book here
you take
some leave and and while you're on leave
you know you go to
where you go dc baltimore area dc yeah
yeah mom was going to college at the
university of maryland um
and then you know you you spend some
time with uh
with mary is that right yeah spend some
time with mary
get to know her and then uh let me give
you some background on mary let's hear
about mary
i met mary dad was stationed in morocco
my dad and 67.
yeah and i went back to morocco
uh for christmas of 67.
met mary one night in church in morocco
in morocco there what was her parents
doing uh they were stationed at the same
navy basically
it was a communications base so she's
another navy brat navy brat
and uh the base is no longer there it
was at city air
uh outside of uh konitra but uh i met
her at church
we went out for a ride my dad's mg the
next day and that was it
and then a year later just before i went
to vietnam i came back and uh met her
parents you know saw her parents and
everything but she'd already gone back
to the states
and so when i came back from vietnam the
first time damn you go
all the way to morocco and marion there
yeah mary ain't there
and uh so so i i came back to the states
and mom said hey
why don't you go down and see uh the
simmons and and i said
yeah we used to live in virginia beach
but that was stationed on the cobbler
uh ss-344 so i thought yeah that'd be
kind of cool i'd like to go back and see
norfolk so i went down there and met her
and we got kind of hooked up then and
that was
that was while you were on leave yeah
that's why i was on my extension leaf
got it so that's you know
kind of a mission accomplished there
yeah yeah stateside mission accomplished
you
you come back from leave
and you you mentioned that you were
ready to go back from leave you were
ready to go back to nam yeah i was ready
to get back i just
i was climbing the walls a little bit um
you get back there hey i read in the
paper in dc that an aircraft went down
wasn't one of ours no one said anything
but everyone looked uncomfortable
finally someone spoke up
yeah it was one of us that was all he
would say well who was it
did the crew get out everyone okay it
was your aircraft
one nine no one got out
what what the what happened i asked i
was in total shock
shock they were on a resupply over a
hover hole
the gooks opened fire on them on their
third pass and they crashed into the
trees
grunt said that they made each of their
three approaches
over the same ground they had five new
replacements on board
their grunts got to the aircraft and
were shooting gooks in the cabin and
cockpit who was the crew it was ash
as ac and newby taylor your crew chief
linman linum is that how you say his
name linum
and dietrich were on board too sorry
they told me i didn't know the co-pilot
who had arrived the day after
i'd left to go home the ac like all our
guys was a good man
good man he had just received a dear
john letter from his wife telling
him she was getting a divorce i guess
she didn't need to know
i guess she didn't need to now i raised
my glass and they joined me
to absent comrades so the guys
lin linum and dietrich who you just went
through that uh
was that called a crash landing what you
did yeah you went through that crash
landing you go home and both those guys
get killed yeah and the thing that's
that struck me was that here i'm in
washington dc i'm reading the paper in
the morning and it's talking about this
helicopter shot down 100 miles north of
saigon i'm thinking
what's so unusual about that i mean
helicopters getting shot down all the
time in vietnam
and i just it just kind of struck me odd
that that would be there and then i get
there and i find out it was my own
aircraft
there's a chapter in here called stand
down and it
it really points out the the importance
of um
crew rest you guys were run ragged clear
i mean you go through one point where
you
you you're in a helicopter flying you
wake up
yeah and you see that the the person
well i guess it's the lead pilot
my co-pilot is also asleep and the
crew's asleep
yeah that happened uh we had a policy it
got to the point where
you know earlier you said in the book
you know if you had 140 hours you got
a couple of days down i was pushing over
160 hours
and it got to the point where most of
the pilots were the same boat we were
short of pilots
uh we were training our crew chiefs uh
to fly the aircraft because it was
getting that desperate
so what we did was if we were flying a
long
leg one pilot would sleep the other
would stay awake
and so that's what we were doing well he
was flying we're coming back at night
beautiful night to fly and i told her i
said i'm gonna i'm gonna get some sleep
he said okay so i closed my eyes and
right away fell asleep
well something's told me to wake up and
i kind of woke up and looked around
and it may have been a one of the first
indications of a problem is a change in
sound in the aircraft
uh you know if suddenly the engine's
quiet you know you got a problem
but there was just you really listen to
sound in the aircraft and that would
that would tell you something's wrong
a whistling sound you just got a bullet
through the rotor blades
so something just woke me up and i just
sat there and just kind of looked around
everything looked great and i looked
over at him
and i thought i wonder what he's looking
at his head was down
and then i realized he's asleep and we
just sat there
and the aircraft was flying along
perfect and then she just
and i suspect what happened is that he
probably just left
a little pressure off his hand and the
cyclic just eased forward a bit because
the nose started dropping
we started picking up speed and pickup
speed sounds going to change the
aircraft started vibrating
and then he woke up and looked over at
me and i went you had a nice nap
so yeah we got back in that night and
the medical officer came
out and they they stood the whole unit
down because i was the third aircraft to
come in that day and
the other two aircraft came in and
pilots both declared that's it
we're done so the medical officer came
out when the company commander came out
and they grounded the whole unit
you guys end up getting a a valorous
unit award
yes yes we got a valles uniform for the
action on six march
69.
um
uh here's another thing that happens uh
you're in for a briefing mr corey you
and i will have three lifts tomorrow
and that should about do it mr roberts
you and i will fly together
the day after tomorrow sir mr roberts
responded looking at
me and i at him you two are going to be
the next flight leaders
the policy about warrant officers not
being flight leaders has changed
you will be first if you guys want the
assignment all the warrants in the room
were smiling and talking softly my
platoon leader
was smiling and while captain weed
wasn't he didn't protest nor did any of
the commissioned officers
i never knew if the major had spoken
with them before the meeting or not
yes sir i'll take it you you alluded to
that earlier
where the real the real life officers
were the only ones that could be flight
leads
and now like you were saying you're so
undermanned that
they open it up and you and one other
guy get to be the first
warren officer flight leads yes they
changed the policy because we're just
we're so short of officers uh
we didn't have any experienced officers
uh that were ready to take over flight
lead positions so
the company commander he went to the
brigade commander and said hey we got to
start letting the experience warrant you
know he said i got i got two warrants
that are over uh over 12 months in the
unit
and these guys know what they're doing
you gotta you gotta open the policy up
and the brigade commander
uh colonel suck really a good guy
uh he said absolutely open it up so you
said you were training some of the crew
chiefs to become pilots did any of them
ever make that transition
while you were in vietnam oh yeah they
could they could they could we would
train them sufficiently to land the
aircraft
not hover or running landing but we
always felt that you know if somebody
got shot
if both pilots got wounded somebody's
gonna have to bring this bird back so
we would train the crew chiefs to do
running landings my crew chief was
pretty darn good at it
and uh one crew chief i think it was
grossman
uh he came back and went to flight
school and graduated from flight school
and came back to nam as a pilot
here we go another mission and look i'm
covering a
tiny percentage of this book and just
trying to figure out which one of these
freaking crazy missions to
to highlight i it just it's like
throwing it's like a roll the dice
pick one they're all they're all nuts
here's one at h minus one the door
gunners open fire concentrating on the
tree line as we touch down the grunt
started
off the aircraft that was when a
sledgehammer hit the side of the
aircraft
one two times and then i lost count the
engine started winding down
the rotor rpm started dropping as the
engine rpm went to zero
where taking fire screamed peters it was
on his side of the aircraft and it was
concentrated on our engine
his gun was ripping through ammunition
get out i yelled
and we began unasking the aircraft chalk
two was leading
the rest of the flight out we were now
on the ground with the grunts
peters was on his m60 machine gun and i
told him to get down
no need for him to sit in the gunners
position and be a target to his credit
he did and took his gun with him
dragging ammo as well
specialist lovelace was doing the same
the cobras were coming in around for a
second pass and using the remaining
rockets and 40 millimeter ammo
that they had rattler 6 was on the
ground next to me and began calling for
artillery support
as the second flight crew flight came
into view the artillery silence and the
anti-aircraft gun that it worked us over
as well as a small arms fire that was
coming from the trees
we remained in the lz until the third
lift and jumped on an aircraft to get
out
already the battalion commander had
notified brigade that an aircraft was
down in the lz
a recovery team was getting ready to
come and get the aircraft and fly it
fly it back under a ch-47 a new engine
would be installed that night
and that aircraft will be flying in the
morning hopefully flying back lovelace
turned to me
damn mr corey you're psychic with your
feelings
and that's something i kind of skipped
over you have a whole a whole chapter
that's called
psychic so you had some kind of whatever
sixth sense about
i i don't think things are gonna go well
i
the first the first time i happened i
went out to the aircraft one day
and just didn't have a good feeling
got got shot up bad that day and
it happened just a second time third
time i came out to the aircraft
i asked lovelace i said hey how's the
aircraft today he goes you got your
feeling don't you
and i kind of lied and i finally said
yeah i just it's gonna be okay guys i
just got a strange feeling
that strange feeling hit me six times
and it just i would go out to the
aircraft
and i would just have this feeling of
dread for that day
and lo and behold we'd get hit and i
just think i'm a believer in
the supernatural and my patron saint is
saint uh padre pio
and i just think padre pio was was
watching over me he blessed me when i
was a little kid and
uh i think he was just watching over me
saying hey
be careful so okay well it's gonna ask
you
like what i i appreciate you saint pio
but just letting me know that i'm gonna
get shot up i need a little bit more
than that
just let me know it's not gonna hit me
yeah
uh that's so so six times you had that
feeling yeah and each time you had that
feeling we got we got them
living daylight shot out of us didn't
lose anybody did you ever have the
feeling it didn't and it didn't happen
yeah yeah i see i had a guy i had a guy
named johnny
and the great guy but man every time we
rolled out
he thought he was we were all going to
die
every time he'd go he'd he smoked chain
smoked and he'd say
niko tonight tonight sir i can feel it
this one you ready
you ready because it's coming every
night it didn't matter what we were
doing we do the logistics run he goes
i got a bad feeling about this one boss
this is coming you'll be like you like
this jocko
you like where this is going i'm like
okay so i had to take that and destroy
it i didn't have saint peel i had
saint johnny we're all gonna die we had
and you know what that guy
went out on every single mission and as
a matter of fact
this is on my first deployment to iraq
and our senior and
my senior enlisted advisor said hey man
you got to get you know get johnny out
of here man get him on the first because
you know it takes
it takes a couple weeks to get everyone
flown home and i said uh
i said he said hey you gotta you know
get talk to johnny get him on that first
bird out of here man he's gonna you know
he's
he's he's losing it and he's not gonna
want to leave and he goes
he goes you need to you need to get him
on a plane and i said i'm not going to
put him on a plane he's not going to
want to leave
and he goes well just ask him and i go
all right fine i'll ask him so i go up
to johnny one day and i said uh
i said hey johnny you know the first
first planes are heading home
uh you want to be you want me to get
your seat on that plane he goes
[ __ ] you i was like roger that
just checking and sure enough he was all
the last bird home you know like
he was he was paranoid but he was doing
his job didn't want to go home
we had a we had a warrant officer that
come into the unit and
he flew made aircraft commander and
never flew a combat mission after that
as aircraft commander
he would he would take the aircraft out
and within 30 minutes you know he'd be
coming back in complaining about
something wrong with the aircraft
and finally they made him an assistant
ops officer and he served as assistant
ops officer but he never flew a combat
mission again
he had a bad feeling yeah he just i i
would say he had a yellow streak he
didn't have a bad feeling he had a
yellow streak
but uh yeah well that was the difference
johnny had that bad feeling all the time
but no
yellow streak there he was ready to rock
and roll
another one on april 30th arvind forces
along with some u.s forces crossed
parrot's beak
into cambodia the arvind forces
consisted of 12
infantry battalions and three ranger
battalions the us
elements consisted of a brigade from the
25th infantry division
tropic lightning and two squadrons of
armed cavalry
operation rock crusher was on so here
this is the first
major operation going into cambodia
because of course the sog guys were
going in there oh they were in there all
the time on may 1st 1970 at 0
7 10 hours company c 227
ahb inserted an arvin airborne rifle
company to secure a landing zone
just across the border inside cambodia
once the landing zone was secured
six hundred and fif hundred 105
millimeter howitzers and 355 millimeter
howitzers which would support additional
insertions throughout the area of
operations were brought in
by ch-47 helicopters later that day the
second battalion seventh cavalry was
inserted into landing zone x-ray marking
the first
american ground troops from the first
cavalry division
to enter cambodia throughout the day 1st
battalion 9th cavalry flew
reconnaissance missions
while elements of the 227th and 229th
helicopter
assault helicopter of italians provided
lift support to arvind grunts and the
228th
assault support helicopter battalion
provided ch-47
heavy lift capability for the movement
of artillery and other
heavy equipment the invasion of cambodia
didn't didn't know what was coming the
night before uh
i got called into the company
commander's office me and reynolds
and uh a couple of platoon leaders and
uh
he said uh he poured eight drinks
scotch we're all sitting there looking
each other like
what the hell is this hey wait how many
of there was you there was about eight
of us in the remainder
one per guy yeah one guy got it
maintenance officer platoon leader
flight leaders
and he said gentlemen i can't tell you
where we're going
but we got a big lift tomorrow and the
maintenance officer had been real stingy
about letting us take an aircraft
and he turned to the maintenance of he
says what's availability tomorrow i mean
his office said sir we got 21 out of 21.
he says good
they turned to uh to me and he says uh
you're chalk two tomorrow if i go down
you take the flight in
i'm thinking what the hell he turned to
reynolds and he says
if corey goes down you take the flight
in
okay sir he says now i want you to get
every one of your pilots and your crew
chiefs up and i want every aircraft
pre-flighted tonight i want maintenance
to know right away
if an aircraft's got a problem but we're
cranking 21 aircraft tomorrow morning
so the next morning we got up all the
birds cranked up colonel
or the boss the ceo he led the assault
we went up to a stage field and we're
sitting there with our 21 aircraft
and here came bravo company where
they're 21
and charlie company with their 21 and
then 10 ch-47s
and we had all of the lobos that was
that was 20 aircraft
and we had uh 20 aircraft from blue max
and we're sitting there going what and
the hell we've never seen this many
battalion commander shows up he takes
map board he throws the
canvas over the map board and says
gentlemen we're invading cambodia
the crew chiefs crew chiefs and
organists all got up and left and went
back and started cleaning guns and
cleaning ammo right away
and we did we picked up uh an arvind
force and uh we flew tree top level
uh the battalion commander was at 3 000
feet he was navigating
uh telling chalk one uh what his heading
was etc
and directing the artillery and the
cobras and
we flew at about oh maybe 200 feet above
the trees
and punched across the border as we went
across the border there was a road
parallel at the border look down there's
guy
nva and their khaki uniforms as far as
you can see down the road both sides of
the roads
sling arms and they're just standing
there kind of shocked that all these
aircraft are passing over them
went in hit the landing zone uh picked
up didn't take any fire going in we
thought oh this is great
took a lot of fire coming back out
across that road but
uh that was the first day of the
cambodian invasion we did three assaults
that day
uh putting vietnamese soldiers in so it
was a big day
then things got hot the next day next
day the nva waiting for the helicopters
and
we started taking a lot of hits the next
days
it's uh it's kind of crazy i always i
always kind of joke about
um hollywood and in hollywood you know
they show like the platoon's about to go
in and
the commander shows up right as the
birds are spinning says all right gents
here's where you're going and here's the
mission and i was talking about how
unrealistic that is but that's what you
guys did well yeah kinda in fact i'm
glad you brought that up because
uh i've got two screenwriters and a uh
a producer right now and the
screenwriters are taking the three
they're taking two books the first two
books and they're writing a screenplay
and one of the things i've told them i
said look guys i do not want this to be
typical hollywood and they're they're
good guys rich graff
who starred in making the mob uh new
york he played lucky luciano in that
and a guy named rocky cartilage and
rocky owns uh
ghost walker productions and then my
producer is amy soto and she's worked
with john malkovich
mel gibson several of these guys so
there there's a good crew
but i told them i said i do not want
this to be a typical hollywood movie
and i and i've given a list of of movies
to watch
this is good ones and this is this is
terrible
i don't want these terrible ones so
we've had some some
lively discussions about what will be in
this movie and not in this movie so
but yeah hollywood just makes it look
kind of odd but when you have an sop
you can say all right this is what we're
going to do and here's how we're going
to do it and you don't take a lot of
discussion with it
and and some of that works out pretty
well it worked out well for me for one
exercise where
i found out my lz the op4
reserve was sitting on my lz
and i grabbed the flight leaders grabbed
the company commander sat down pulled
the poncho over our heads
turned the flashlight on said okay
here's your new lz's any questions no
let's go
so you can do that stuff if you have a
system and if you have a good working
procedure but
yeah some of the stuff that hollywood
puts out is just
um here's one
mayday mayday dragon breath 2 3 is
bailing out and going down
vicinity and there's the grid
coordinates you all are in the air watch
the parachute go down
so there's a guy bailing out of of one
of these he's a four-door observer so
what's he in an ob10
he was in yeah he no uh
what was that twin tail cessna
they had a push-pull yeah yeah i don't
know i don't remember the nomenclature
on it but it was it wasn't the ov-10
but he was in one of those when he went
down so
this guy punches out of his aircraft
and you guys are on this operation
looking watching this parachute go down
watch you know track and as it goes into
the jungle
you're flying you're looking for it and
here we go
as captain beauchamp slid the aircraft
over the pilot
sergeant west informed him sir the pilot
appears to be out cold he's just hanging
there
hanging in the tree there okay we have
to get him quick quick captain beauchamp
said
surveying the ground for a place to land
there wasn't one as the vegetation
wasn't dense but the trees were 30 feet
high and close enough together that it
didn't offer a clearing big enough to
land in
west had already climbed into the cabin
area and was preparing a 200-foot repel
rope
that was maintained in the aircraft sir
i can get him
and with that he dropped the rope and
was prepared preparing to go down
okay but and west was gone he'd
forgotten to put gloves on and his hands
were paying for that mistake
how am i gonna get him out he said more
to himself than anyone particular
jameson you keep an eye on him and keep
him covered
captain beauchamp said to the door
gunner dropping
the 70 feet or so west sprinted to the
pilot who is still unconscious and
hanging in the tree
only a few feet off the ground small
tufts of graft
grass and dirt were being kicked up
around west as small arms fire was
directed
in his direction damn parachute release
won't release son of a [ __ ] damn it
come on wes screamed hoping the pilot
would wake
and give him some assistance he did not
gotta get a knife
pausing at a low crouch west waited a
moment before he sprinted back to the
aircraft which was still at a hover
engaging the nva position as he ran west
made a cutting motion
hoping the gunner or co-pilot would
recognize the signal
and drop a knife they did picking up the
knife west didn't hesitate to sprint
back to the hanging pilot
cut him free and throw him over his
shoulder just then an rpg round slammed
into the tree
the pilot had been hanging in with the
pilot over his shoulder in a fireman
carry position
west ran for the aircraft and the
dangling rope
grabbing the rope he wrapped it around
the pilot and himself and motioned for
the aircraft to take off
west didn't have time to tie a knot but
only had the rope wrapped around himself
in the pilot
because of his rope burned hands west
couldn't climb the rope
but pradee could hold on long enough to
get safely back to ground
as the aircraft climbed out and built up
some speed small arms fire continued
captain beauchamp didn't fly couldn't
fly with any speed as the drag
on west and the pilot would be too great
and pull them off the rope
west was dangling about 70 feet below
the aircraft which was flying over the
jungle
at two to three hundred feet helicopter
crews did not have parachutes
as west cleared the trees captain
beauchamp nosed the aircraft over and
began picking up speed all the while
praying west didn't fall
everyone was well aware that if they had
an engine failure
or any other emergency west and the
pilot wouldn't survive
arriving over a clearing captor
beauchamp captain beauchamp lowered the
aircraft to place west and the pilot on
the ground
and then the aircraft this was an
unsecured clearing only about 1500
meters from where they picked up the
pilot
detaching the rope west and jameson
quickly loaded the pilot into the
aircraft and departed
for lz center where the unconscious
pilot was quickly transferred to a
medevac aircraft that had been requested
west resumed his duties as crew chief
wes went on to receive he was put in for
the medal of honor
it was downgraded to the distinguished
service cross and he spent 20 years in
the army retired as a command sergeant
major
at fort eustis virginia
uh yeah that's um
that's a that's a that's a crazy story
and and the crazy stories just kind of
continue they they just kind of continue
uh throughout this book just incredible
heroics on every page
um you end up getting commissioned you
end up getting commissioned now do they
commission you as an infantry officer
while you're there do does that is that
orders that you get that you have to
wait for
no no i got commissioned while i was
there as an infantry officer battlefield
commission basically
totally surprised the living daylights
out of me you know what what it happened
i i got i was getting calls that that
morning i got a call from somebody
saying
hey uh mr corey understand you're going
to battalion
i said what are you talking about i'm
not going to battalion yeah it's uh
understand you're going to the battalion
i'm thinking
that's impossible i extended to stay in
the unit well a little while later
my platoon leader beauchamp jumps up on
my skid says i'm getting refueled he
taps me on the show he says damn i hate
to see you leave you know
send the good missions to us when you
get up there on battalion staff i'm
thinking oh cripe
my team leader's saying this this might
be true throughout the day i keep
getting radio calls hey dan sorry to see
you leave hammerhammer
so that night i get to the you know i
get back in i'm really dejected i'm
feeling down i throw my gear in the room
i go over to the bar and get a beer
company commander walks in he says hey
everybody get a beer i need your
attention
so i'm thinking oh cripe so he gets in
he says hey i got good news and i got
bad news i said the first good news
first bad news okay he says corey come
up here
so i'll go up there and he says uh you
all know corey's been with us now what
16 months down i said yeah it's been
about that sir
and he says you know everybody's flown
with him you've done a great job
hamahama
but uh it's time for you to leave so
we're gonna miss you dan
but uh we know you'll go forth and do
great things for us congratulations
so i go back up and get on my bar stool
i'm sitting there and he says now we
but the good news is we got a new new
guy's arriving he's got about
1600 hours of flying time and a lot of
experience and that's what we need
guys with a lot of experience here in
the unit let's welcome
the new guy lieutenant cory and i'm
sitting here at the bar and i'm not
facing him facing the
bar mate i'm going lieutenant cory that
dude's got the same last name as me i
wonder where the hell he's from
i turned around and everybody's looking
at me
and the old man looks at me says come up
here lieutenant cory
and so i thought wait a minute they're
talking about me
so i get up walk up there and he
congratulated me and somebody had put me
in for a direct commission the first
lieutenant
so i was the first lieutenant in the
infantry now
is there no such thing as how can you
not a first lieutenant
pilot is that is that not a thing well
see at that time we didn't have an
aviation branch the army had
uh um they had all the other branches
but we didn't have an aviation branch
and there was some politics involved
with that with the air force
and they did not form the aviation
branch in the army until
about 1985 and at that time you had a
choice if you were an infantry officer
if you were another branch you could
decide if you're going to go to the
aviation branch
or retain the branch that you were in
and i retained the infantry branch
because
i lost the the retina my left eye just
before that so
i would have been able to fly anyway so
i just stayed in the infantry
so back to the book a little bit i mean
so you get this commission
you're you're still conducting all kinds
of missions i'm jumping through all
kinds of missions
um you're starting to get short meaning
you're close to heading home
yep um picking it up here i was in
the chalk two position and it just
cleared the trees and was really paying
no attention to chalk three who
attempted to fly between two trees
and caught a rotor blade on one yeah to
everyone's heart the aircraft slowly
rode
rolled to the right where the damaged
rotor blade made contact with the ground
when it did the rotor blades began to
disintegrate
with pieces flying everywhere soldiers
in the back began falling out of the
aircraft
and they were fortunate and they were
the fortunate ones as the aircraft was
now descending toward the ground
as the right side impacted the
transmission was ripped from its mounts
and tore through the cargo compartment
as the aircraft came to a stop the
engine was still running
now at ever increasing rpm as there was
no rotor to turn
or transmission connected fuel began to
spill across the engine
at this time the aircraft aircraft were
not equipped with self-sealing fuel
cells that would prevent a major fire
the aircraft began to burn and burn
rapidly
as bill had been waiting for chalk three
and four to take off
he was only he was only light on his
skids when the accident happened
his crew chief door door gunner and
captain head
immediately jumped out and ran to pull
people out of the aircraft
soldiers on the ground also moved
forward to assist lightning
and that was a call sign one of the guys
was attempting to climb out but was
dazed
and having difficulty moving quickly to
assist lightning captain head was having
difficulty as well as the fire was
now in the cockpit and spreading rapidly
the co-pilot was consumed in the flames
as was the crew chief
the gunner could not be seen as he was
under the aircraft having occupied the
right side of the aircraft that day
finally lightning was extracted from the
wreckage and fire
yeah yeah that's the story that you told
earlier yeah yeah lightning uh
that was his name is john copenhaver a
great guy
and his nickname was lightning because
john just always kind of walked kind of
slow
kind of talked a little on the slow side
but we all loved him dearly
and he was he was really a great platoon
leader as well
and but yeah they hit this tree and i
was always worried about john and this
this particular crate seat pilot flying
together uh there'd been an incident the
month before with them flying together
and they landed on some stumps
and there's just
something about this right seat pilot
that the day i met him i looked at him
and said
this kid's not going to make it there's
nothing about him tell me you know he
wasn't competent
he was he was a halfway decent pilot
he was a nice guy but there was just
something about it that told me
he ain't gonna make it and so they had
that first accident him and john
and i was kind of concerned about them
flying together again but i i didn't
make flight assignments so there's
nothing i could do about it
and then they had this happen and hit
the tree and
we got john out we didn't get anybody
else out and
john spent six six weeks in a coma and
uh
but he's doing quite well today listen
lives in maryland rockport maryland i
think it is but he's doing well so
you say no one was in good spirits that
evening everyone
in both the officers club and enlisted
man's club wasn't a sober mood
it hurt even more when we were informed
that the division commander's aircraft
was missing and presumed crash
my good friend bill do you say michael
mike bill michael was the pilot
the division commander was major general
casey a very much like
division commander very good guy casey
casey was a super
he had been the division assistant
division commander and then uh
moved up to gorez division commander
hadn't hadn't been division committed
very long
but he was a guy that was always out
there with us uh
you you be in an lz or you get back to a
refuel point
in their case you'd be in he'd be
talking to you like okay how'd it go
you know what problems you got how's the
aircraft running maintenance working
okay
uh he was concerned he was he was what
everybody considered
a good leader and we were all
very much down we found out they crashed
into a mountaintop in bad weather
then this happens lieutenant cory sir
you got your orders you're going home
you're to report to two division rear no
later than tomorrow
we have a bird waiting for you at 1400
today to take you to ben hoa
what what are you talking about sir you
are to report to division rear casualty
assistance office you best get packing
fast
it suddenly dawned on me bill's parents
had requested that i bring bill's
remains home yeah i was close with his
family
i stayed there before i went to vietnam
and then when i came home on leave
and before i went back again i stayed
with this mom and dad great
great people up there they lived in
monroe washington outside of snohomish
he had a little brother that had just
gotten into the air force academy
bill was really proud of norm and this
happened
and they they had me be the escort
officer to bring bill home
you say arriving at the funeral home
this is after you get back arriving at
the funeral home i made sure bill was
settled in
for the night and then i was taken to
bill's parents house in monroe
washington
mom and pop wanted me to stay with them
as they considered me family
two other couples were there with mom
and pop when i arrived
after putting my bags away in the
upstairs bedroom
i came into the dining room where they
were all seated
dan what are you drinking pop ass i
wasn't much of a drinker except beer
but took a scotch on the rocks when i
sat down mom placed her hand on mine and
asked what happened he was a vip pilot
she was a tough woman but i could see
from the puffy eyes that she had been
crying
i tried to explain as calmly in as much
detail as i could
what had happened bad weather bad maps
but i didn't have the heart to say that
the general is probably flying the
aircraft
generals could fly but not in weather
and on top of that
bill wasn't instrument rated either but
could handle the aircraft in weather
conditions
then the hard part came bill's in the
casket but i advise that it be a closed
cast
casket ceremony i said before taking a
sip of scotch
why is that asked pop well there was an
explosion
and fire his body is in a plastic bag
under a glass case
on the glass case is his uniform with
all his decorations
the glass case is held down by 300
screws
opening the lid is easy but not the
glass case
the rest of the evening was spent
telling good stories of bill
from flight school and our one mission
in vietnam together
between drinks and teary eyes we got
through the night
the day of the funeral came and bill's
sister judy arrived early with her
husband and children to cook breakfast
the ride to church was quiet and we all
sat together in the front of the church
it was packed as monroe was a small town
and everyone knew the michaels
the preacher stood and gave the eulogy
praising the work bill had done in the
community
and for the nation he said that bill was
not afraid of death
but loved life few helicopter crews in
vietnam
were afraid of death it was part of the
job but they all loved life
they were some of this nation's finest
when the preacher finished sex army
pallbearers came forward
hoisted bill's casket and solemnly moved
outside to the hearse
at the gravesite i lowered my salute and
accepted the flag from the commander of
the burial detail
executing a smart about face i walked
over to mom
thinking that this was one strong woman
as i saw no tears
standing in front of her i knelt and
said on behalf of a grateful nation i
present this flag
that was what i had been instructed to
say but in my heart i had my doubts
about this being a grateful nation
standing slowly i came to attention and
again
raised a slow salute
in the distance the command for the
firing squad could be heard
and three volleys of seven rounds each
caused many to jump
as the 21 gun salute was fired
on the last volley of the three the
distant sound of taps was heard
no one held back tears at this point
i slowly lowered my salute turned and
walked to the side
my official's duties concluded
as many started to leave i came back put
my arms around mom
and wept just like every other human
there
and i weep to this day
yeah that was uh that was kind of a hard
hard period for me going through the the
funeral with them
i picked norm up at the airport from the
air force academy they gave him
leave emergency leave and
he was home for that and and he
struggled his first year through that
academy
uh because of this but he got through
just fine he became a c-141 pilot
uh and he went to work for the airlines
and he's retired from that now so
he's doing well we stay in touch and mom
and pop they've passed away
at this point but uh yeah bill was a
great guy we got the chance to fly
together one time
uh had had a kick a kick day that day
picked him up he'd never flown a combat
mission you know flying vips around
that's all he ever did
so i picked him up went out to a fire
basin they had a battalion commander out
there he was crazy as hell
had a big red bow on the back of his
helmet and i never asked him why that
was there
but he get there and he says uh hey yeah
how do you feel
how do you feel about dropping bombs i
said sir wouldn't really not equip the
drop bumps because
yeah you're equipped dropped these bombs
he said how do you feel i said well yeah
we'll do it so we get out to the
aircraft and they got this box
that's on the one end of it's sitting on
the floor and the other ends up on
stands and in this box he's got
about six 81 millimeter mortar rounds
with aerial bomb fuses in the nose and
tape tied around the tails
any and so what we did is we flew along
2000 feet
and we went over these four crossing
points on the river
and as the as the the crossing point
came up through the petals
i would say mark mark mark and they'd
open the door on that box and these
mortar rounds would fall out at 2 000
feet and it was just like a bombing run
and we did this about
four or five times that day and bill
thought you guys are crazy this is great
stuff
and then we did a log mission that he'd
never done before he'd never been down
how how accurate were the uh
it was darn accurate it was really it
was really pretty darn good accuracy
uh surprise eleven days but the
battalion commander said he says i don't
have any mortars in this range but i
want the nva to think
that we've got guys pretty close to them
so that's the reason we were doing that
and we did we did one combat assault and
uh
bill just he was excited when the day
was over we flew about 10 hours that day
but uh yeah he really enjoyed that day
and then it was
it wasn't two months later that uh that
he crashed up there
so so now you're home from vietnam yep
and you're you
you're now going to become an infantry
officer you talked about your retina
when did that happen
uh that happened in 83. oh okay so
so you still could fly but you still but
you have to become an infantry officer
is that how it works yeah yeah i was an
infantry officer so i went uh i got home
and went to fort benning attended the
infantry officer basic course
went to fort lewis washington took
command of a infantry company up there
and then we formed the ninth infantry
division up
that had been stood down in vietnam but
they stood it back up i was there
so i was there as the aviation officer
for the first brigade so i was back to
flying again
then i went to fort benning for the
advance course then went to alaska
are they are they taking you with your
combat experience and throwing you as
sort of a leadership position in these
oh yeah yes company commanders uh i got
to alaska and they made me the
operations officer for the air cavs
squadron
so i was up there for that for a year
and then uh on a friday night i got a
phone call saying
you you need to report to anchorage on
monday morning
we just relieved the company commander
of the airborne company and you're going
to take them out of the airborne company
why do you get relieved i didn't ask
that question
[Laughter]
jack so you roll in and take it so now
you're company commander company
commander
of one of the airborne companies in
alaska how did you like grunt work
i loved it i loved grunt work uh
i enjoyed flying but i honestly one day
was thinking when i was flying you know
i'm
i'm really a glorified greyhound bus
driver
[Laughter]
and and i saw all the things that was to
do in the army and i want to do other
things besides fly that helicopter so
when they say you're going to be an
infantry officer i had no complaints
about that i loved grunt work
uh commanding that airborne company in
alaska
uh people go well it's 30 below zero
you're going to jump out of an airplane
yeah let's jump
uh so he did that and then uh so what
year is it now
uh that was eight that was 78.
i was commanding the airborne company 79
they made me the operations officer for
the infantry battalion
how was the how was the post-vietnam
years in the army
terrible absolutely terrible uh
we didn't have any any ammunition to
train with in fact the soldiers
they would charge up a hill and a
training exercise and they go bang bang
bang 13 cents
bang bang bang 13 cents because that was
the cost of training rounds
uh 13 cents a round but we didn't even
have training rounds
uh it was really pretty bad in the army
uh we went through
a period from 70 to 75
where we were rifting captains
and that just killed the morale in the
captain's
ranks uh i was in the advanced course in
there at fort benning we had 10 200 man
classrooms on one side of the building
10 200 million classrooms on the other
side of the building
all full all of them infantry captains
back from vietnam
and on one day they walked in and
from being a 200 man class every one of
those rooms went down to be in 140 man
class
those captains were pulled out they told
you have 90 days to get out
or you can avert to being a sergeant one
or the other wow
so and they did that for four years so
that really ruined the morale and the
captains
ranks so no it was not the early years
after vietnam were not
not good years in the army before uh one
more question about vietnam
um this is a question i bring up and you
already talked about it but um
you said most of the guys that you had
most of the crew chiefs most of the most
of the support people that weren't
flying
they were people that had volunteered
was it was it if you were going to be a
dork could you be
just assigned a door gun or was those
all those people volunteers
uh door gunners were volunteers may have
they have been drafted and then they
volunteered for
that's what a lot of them were they were
drafted into the infantry they did a
tour in the infantry and then they
volunteered to come be a door gunner got
it
so could you tell the difference between
someone that was a draftee and someone
that was a
lifer no you really couldn't there was
and the guys that were drafted you know
people say oh they had bad attitudes
i never saw it they all had a good
attitude they were all in this together
now what did happen guys that that were
drafted
when they came back from number they
still had a year left they would send
them to germany
and there's where the problems were all
at in germany uh they had
big-time morale problems there what are
you going to do send me back to vietnam
and bent my dog tags
it got to the point in germany in the
early 70s where the duty officers
were armed with 45s yeah
they had one incident over there where a
duty officer was stuffed in a wall
locker
throwing out a second story window yeah
the morale in germany
in the early 70s was not good at all uh
but in vietnam
the very seldom saw a problem i had one
problem once in the aircraft where an e6
just refused to go to the field last i
saw of him the mps had him and they were
driving away with him but
that was it so now now we're in the
in the 70s bringing but bring us back to
time it's just
morale is horrible it's it's tough it's
tough especially in the officers court
because
because of all the rifts going on guy
doesn't know he's gonna have a job next
month or not
uh what are they basing it on how do you
know if you're gonna get ripped or not
you don't it's basically it's not
performance it's just numbers
it's it's i i would like to think it was
based upon your efficiency reports
but we had a guy in my class had
distinguished service cross they rifted
him
what yep yeah
all of us all of us said the same thing
how in the hell did he get rifted i mean
he's got the distinguished service cross
this is in 73 and he got rifted
uh one of the guys that i work with in
charlie had he had silver stars a couple
of silver stars a
purple heart a couple of distinguished
flying crosses
got rifted he's now he got out and he
became
the i think the eastern manager for
michelin tires
but you didn't know it was supposed to
be based on efficiency reports
and i think at some point in time they
just said all these guys have got great
efficiency reports we just got to have
numbers now
and if you're a reserve officer
uh up till 75 you were definitely in the
hunt to get rifted
regular army officers didn't face that
the next rift
76 regular army officers were in that
boat too
so uh yeah it's just it got bad
so you're just keeping your fingers
crossed basically yep yep
i hope to god the army never has to go
through that again
do you know do you know off the top of
your head how much smaller the army got
from 1970 to 1978
no i don't i don't there's just a
massive downsizing massive downsizing
i can tell you this today you could take
all the 11 bravo infantrymen in the army
and put them in rfk stadium and you'd
still have empty seats
so the army's not nearly as big as it
used to be well not even close
not even close that's crazy you know
today we rely a lot on the national
guard and the army reserve and they've
really stepped up they stepped up in
desert storm
uh and and a lot of the animosity that
existed
in the 70s between the active army and
the army guard and the army reserves
a lot of that disappeared thank god
during desert storm uh
well i worked with the national guard
all the time in in
iraq and they were freaking awesome yeah
they were outstanding outstanding
professionals yep
they've stepped up and done a great job
i was the aviation advisor from maryland
for two years and
uh we had an aviation maintenance
company that was fantastic
we took them down to bragg every year
and fort bragg always wanted these guys
to come down and work on the aircraft
for them they're just really super
so so so this time so you're continuing
kind of up through the ranks you become
uh you do your company commander tour
what comes after that uh
company commander then i was uh an
instructor
at the army commanding general staff
college i was a tactics instructor
and then i got tagged kicking and
screaming
to go to germany as an exchange officer
in the german army for two years
teaching tactics interoperability issues
with german forces
then came back went to fort campbell and
in fact we got a phone call in the
middle of the night
and a guy called me and he said this is
the
personnel officer for the 101st airborne
division how quick can you get here
and i said sir i could be there in five
days
he said start packing stuff you'll be
here in five days i turned around on my
wife and said
start getting the stuff off the wall
it's where being transferred back to the
states in five days she started to laugh
at me
20 minutes later the phone rang it was
my boss he says you are relieved from
that assignment
get the four campbell as fast as you can
what was that all about uh there was
something coming down
and they needed me to be there to be the
brigade executive officer for the
for the second brigade did you know
someone there was one of your friends or
something
didn't know anybody just just random
just random branch branch pulled my hat
name out of the hat and said get to fort
campbell and so what was your role then
i was the executive officer for the
brigade second brigade oh okay
and then uh i was at for two years and
then i went over to command of
3rd battalion 327th infantry for two
years and had that during desert storm
so tell us about desert storm uh
it got boring tell you the trips
sitting out there in the desert you know
we i i had the task force at west point
training the cadets for the summer and
my exo was sitting there he's reading
the sunday newspaper he says hey you
know this is
what the heck's going on with iraq and
kuwait so we read that and i say you
know billy if they go into kuwait we're
gonna go to war
and i think it was two weeks later it
was in the wall street it was in the new
york times
and two weeks later he got the call and
i turned the building i said let's get
out of here
so right away we got the west point
staff we planned out what we had to get
done that week
and to get out of there so when we got
the call on a friday night to get out of
west point
we were gone the next morning and got
back to campbell had three weeks back at
campbell before we'd shipped out to
to iraq or out to saudi arabia
well if if saddam had attacked we
we in the 82nd would have been speed
bumps
and thank god he didn't attack but we
went up and sat about
60 miles from the border and we had a
defensive position set up there and
that's where we sat from
august to february january to january
oh man good times oh yeah sitting out
there in the middle of the desert you
know
at least you were there in time for
summer yeah yeah in
august well it made us appreciate when
when when february
january rolled when you were now
freezing yeah now we're freezing at
night
so but yeah we sat up there and just ran
tactical exercises and like we would
back in the states you know it was it
was
it was different because we'd always
trained in in forests and woods and
stuff like that
but we got up there we said all right
we're a new environment let's learn how
to do this new environment so we spent a
lot of time
learning desert techniques studying up
on what the desert rats had done
in world war ii uh looking at some stuff
that we've received from sas about
desert operations
and just started practicing that stuff
and the kids the kids did great the
soldiers did fantastic
and and then the the war kicks off and
you did i get that right when i opened
up you that was the largest
airborne assault ever it was the largest
air air mobile
air mobile assault sorry yeah air
assault ever and for people that don't
know air assault is with helicopters
airborne is with parachutes yeah
so it was the largest era how so what
the hell did that look like
you know i talked about in the book
about we had uh 60s hueys and you know
10 snooks and
all those cobras well this made that
look small because these were all
blackhawks
and uh blackhawks do you have any idea
how many i think
uh let's see we probably had close to 80
blackhawks
and 80 blackhawks all taking off at the
same time
and we took off from several different
locations and then joined up in the air
and and flew in for this thing and
i am sure that the iraqis that we flew
over just kind of
oops oops uh because we got we got in
there and there was uh
there were four or five positions that
uh that were set up that that we went
into right away
and took over and what we did is we set
up a big perimeter out there
so we did you you guys flew into iraq oh
yeah yeah and then you hit the ground
and we're your your mission tasking was
to secure some positions where our
mission task was to secure this big area
that right away they started flying in
fuel blivets
and we were securing for lack of a
better term a giant gas station
for the cobras and the apaches the
apaches were flying out of there going
after the
iraqi tanks and stuff so we we sat there
for
my battalion sat there for two days
doing that and then we flew out and went
with another brigade to another location
and secured that for the gas station
i was going to stay shocked though we
got to that second location
we were engaged in some iraqis and my s3
came up and said sir ceasefire
i said what are you talking about cease
fire we're in the middle of contact here
cersei's fire it's word came down from
brigade we have to cease fire
i said you go back and call brigade for
clarification on that i'm not cease
firing right now somebody's shooting at
us
and he came back he said ceasefire so
we were shocked after four days this
thing's over with and all the troops
oh it was a ceasefire because the war
was over yeah yeah
and all the troops said the same thing
we're going to be back here
sir we're going to what what are we
doing we're going to be back here
someday
we can't stop now and we did
did you take any casualties uh i had one
soldier dislocate his shoulder
that was it i'll take it yeah yeah
in fact that was kind of kind of unique
because when i when i took command of
the battalion my training guidance i
gave it to the battalion and i said that
in conclusion
we will go forth we will win the we'll
win the last battle of the next war
and we will win the entire war and we
will bring everybody home
i didn't realize i was going to bring
everybody home alive but i was happy to
do that so
that worked out good when you were when
you were getting ready
during that august to whenever the
invasion kicked off
did you were you thinking it could be a
major battle and major casualties
because i so i came in the navy in 1990
and i remember they were saying on the
news there's going to be 40
000 casualties in the first 48 hours yes
in fact our operational plans my last
objective was the airport at baghdad
we had planned it out that far as where
we were going to go and so when we got
the word stop after four days we're
going
what in the world has gone on i have
heard
because because right now i'll put a
shameless plug in
i'm writing another three book series on
desert storm
and and i have found out in my research
that one of the reasons that we stopped
was because turkey did not want us to
overthrow saddam because saddam they
felt was the only one to keep the kurds
in check
and turkey said don't go to iraq
and then schwarzkopf's guidance was kick
him out of kuwait
he didn't have any guidance supposedly
to go after him in iraq so that's one of
the reasons we stopped but
yeah we thought we were going to go all
the way to baghdad
very disappointed that we didn't
yeah well so what'd you do after that
what was the next move uh the next move
was to
to an army headquarters that was
worthless headquarters in the army
and i did two years there after i got
promoted
and then they said sorry next time it's
the pentagon and i said
i'll take the option thank you very much
so i went ahead and retired
93 and uh
now you have you have two sons yes two
sons both boys
uh yeah they're sons they're boys
jay he joined the marine corps
reserves while i was commanding when i
first got command of my battalion
and i came home from a field exercise
that just
kicked my butt i walked in the house and
my lovely wife mary is standing there
and she's got her arms crossed and she
said guess what your son did
i'm thinking my son you know
as far as i know it's our son i know
that
jay what'd you do he goes semper fi i
went you joined the marine corps he said
dad dad i joined the marine corps
reserves i just
he says he was in college and he says
i'm just tired of going to school
i'm going to go in the reserves i'll
drop out of school one semester
i'll do you know my two weeks in the
summer one weekend each
each each month and and you know i just
wanted a break
so i said okay that sounds good
mary's standing there she goes well what
if they have to go to war
and i said mary the marine corps reserve
hasn't gone to war since korea and
nothing's gonna happen there you go
there you go words thanksgiving day i'm
standing on the iraqi
the iraqi saudi border my brigade
commander flies in he goes uh
hey you call home lately
and i said yes sir there's a phone booth
behind every sand dune out here no i
haven't called home since we got here
he said well you need to call home when
we get you back to eagle
and i said what's happened he says your
son's unit got activated he's on his way
so three days three days before the air
war started i got a chance to go down to
where the marines were at
i got to spend the day with him and i'm
sitting there as we're
we're leaving and i'm looking at him and
i'm going
damn he's just a little kid so i got
back i was
talking to my brigade commander tom hill
and he says damn jay just looked like a
little kid
tom reached over and tapped my lady says
every one of your troops is just one of
those little kids and i got
damn he's right i'm the oldest guy in
that battalion he's right they're all a
bunch of kids
so but jay came through fine and then
came back got a two-year rotc commission
or rotc scholarship and came in the army
as an armor officer
and now he's an 0-6 and nato
headquarters in brussels chris
uh he did the same thing quit college
joined the army i got a phone call from
a recruiter one night saying hey i got
your son here we're gonna sign him up
for four years
and i said no you're not you're gonna
sign him up for two so
and chris wound up back in my brigade
the first brigade of the 101st
uh and the scout platoon got out uh went
to college came back in on an rotc
commission infantry
and uh he just retired two years ago as
lieutenant colonel and
he got he was in the infantry and then
he
got over into strategic intelligence a
good friend of ours uh
lieutenant general uh fridavich an
sf guy taught chris going into strat
intel
and chris has done a lot of work in that
that arena there with
with you guys and some other people so
he just retired a couple years ago
he's back in the pentagon doing the same
job back in the same office so
he can't wait to get out of there and
come down to florida
and what did you do after after you
retired uh two days after i retired i
started uh as a real estate
appraiser a friend of ours had an
appraisal company and found out i was
retiring and said why don't you come do
this so
i went up there and saw what it was
about and thought yeah i don't have to
work for the government and it's back in
the town that we want to live in
makes a decent wage so why not so went
back up there and spent two years as an
apprentice
doing that and then took my my exams
passed those and
just kept doing real estate appraising
for 20 years or so
and then what at what point did you
decide you're going to write the books
uh we came down here in 20
or down here we came to florida 2016.
that's when i
finally said okay i'm fully retired
sailed my boat down
from tennessee sailed it over and
uh my wife had a problem come up she
couldn't get on the boat anymore
we had a 36-foot sailboat so i thought
okay i'm going to sell the sailboat
uh she can't get on it we're not going
to can't do cruising
i was doing boat deliveries from panama
and mexico but
she never went on those so but anyway
so suddenly i didn't have anything to do
and
we we went down to the to the dav
because see about this this retina and
we're talking to the guy
and he said something about vietnam
and i broke down i mean big time
and he said have you ever been evaluated
for ptsd
and i said no he said we're getting you
evaluated
and they sent me over to the va for an
evaluation i had always thought
and i hate to say this but i always
thought ptsd was a bunch of bull
i thought it was just a sham and i'm
sitting there with him
my wife and i'm crying and they took me
over there and i got evaluated
and they put me in a 16-week program
with a psychiatrist
and for about eight weeks we spent
one day a week me crying and working
through this thing
so one of the things he suggested he
says you know why don't you write
everything down that happened while
you're in vietnam
so i said all right so i started writing
the first book
and at first i started write it as an
autobiography and i thought well hell
nobody's going to read this so
i'll make it a novel so i wrote it as a
novel
and went to a reunion in 2019
of our our unit it's the first time i'd
ever been to one so i took the book with
me
and presented it there and the guys
loved it
and they said well what about what about
this what about this
why didn't you include this so i wrote
the second book
and did that and put that out there
and it's had great reviews and then guys
started calling me hey
you know we were in lomson 719 the
biggest battle that army aviation has
ever been in
why don't you write a book about that so
i wrote the second book or the third
book
and uh put that out and now they've come
back and said well we love the third
book but
we want more of the wife's side as to
what wives are going through when this
battle is going on they're hearing about
it
so right now i'm drafting out a fourth
book that'll that'll be coming out
sometime
after i get this this series that i'm
working on now about desert storm
anyone who's who kind of guided you
through the writing process
uh there's a guy named uh james
rosen and james wroten a couple of books
a couple he's got a bunch out there and
he wrote one interview with a terrorist
he was an interrogator
and he wrote that and he wrote a couple
of books my mommy has ptsd
my daddy has ptsd and he wrote those and
i read one of his books he's got a
series called rigged and i read that
and i wrote him sent him an email saying
hey i really enjoyed reading your books
welcome to find out he lives around the
corner from me and he called me up he
said let's go to buffalo wings and
we went to buffalo wings and he's been
kind of my mentor guiding me through
uh on how to write the process of how to
get published and we publish on amazon
i fixed me up with a great editor she's
really good drives i drive her crazy
but so he's been kind of guiding me
along
and then i got this while here about we
need to make a movie
and we're working right now on that with
the with the two screen writers and my
my producer any any idea when that's
going to
come to fruition well we're hoping to
have the screenplay done by the end of
the summer
and the producer is putting together the
package that we're going to start taking
to the studios
i'm just hoping that i'll still be alive
when we get it on the screen you know
it takes it's about a three to four year
process i'm finding that
to get a movie made yeah no i i think
that's a a minimum and it can the other
weird thing about movies are
you can you can sell a screenplay
tomorrow
for a millions of dollars and it can
never get made yeah
you can just sit and someone someone
buys it from from you and it just sits
there and that's the way it is sometimes
i would rather have it made than make a
million dollars and i know people are
gonna go
yeah right i think our story is
important enough that it needs to get
out there uh i've already talked to a
couple of organizations what money we
make on this
a lot of it is going to get donated back
to the army aviation association
the wings of liberty museum at fort
campbell uh
the american huey huey
huey chapter 365
i mean these are outfits that have been
helping me out and stuff like that so
that's our intent is to get a lot of
this money donated back to those that
helped us
well that's that's awesome um look we've
been going for
over three hours right now i i i uh
well i kind of we should probably wrap
this thing up for people to
find you um online i know you have you
have
mattjacksonbooks.com is that the main
place to
find you uh they can find us at
www.mattjacksonbooks.com
uh we're on facebook matt jackson we're
on facebook undaunted valor
and uh very soon we were going to have a
website for the movie
uh the galaxy effect she sent me an
email yesterday i got to see her on
saturday
and we will have that out coming out
pretty soon the books are all for sale
on amazon
uh that's who we work with for for
publishing stuff
yeah and we'll we'll have those linked
up so people can just we have a thing on
our website
called books from the podcast we'll
we'll have all these on there so people
can click right in
and get the books echo yes
do you have anything i do okay see now
now we get to the real part of the year
yeah yeah
it's one he seemed awful quiet over
there okay what's going through his mind
uh okay so when you started working with
the uh the screenwriters
right and you were like hey these movies
don't follow this
you know bs but these movies you sort of
can
what were the movies that you kind of
can't like that had some integrity with
their profession oh uh
hacksaw ridge uh that's great
one of the best ones is hamburger hill i
thought that was
that was a pretty good production that
they need to focus on
uh one of the ones i said no to
was uh what was the clint east one
where he's a marine oh uh heartbreak
heartbreak ridge no no no no
uh 1917 i thought was pretty good
uh those those are the three big ones
that that i focus these guys on looking
at
what about saving private right oh
saving privates definitely
good right yeah that's that's a great
one all right what about apocalypse now
absolutely not what about platoon
because we had a platoon's a good one oh
okay all right potentially never seen
platoon you never have yeah
i tell you what he was reprimanded but
you haven't seen cobra
so i haven't seen cobra either of course
so
yeah when you guys watch cobra then yeah
you added to your list platoon was one
of the first good ones that came out
you know apocalypse now came out and
yeah because that came out in 75. yeah
and that was such i don't want to say
the word on the air but
absolutely not i nearly threw up
watching that in fact i never watched
the whole thing
i watched bits and pieces here and there
and just that told me i didn't want to
see this thing
but platoon came out and it was pretty
darn realistic
uh i love the part where uh in hamburger
hill
where they make them brush their teeth
as soon as they arrive happened to us in
vietnam as soon as we got off the
airplane we had to brush our teeth
so you know stuff like that was pretty
realistic to what was going on where
apocalypse now was blowing smoke
well when uh the the joke that
i forget who who it was they played a
joke and you said hey don't salute me
that was right that was our operations
officer when i got there yeah okay so
that's from a scene from
forrest gump by the way yeah yeah yeah
he's like delicious
yeah yeah yeah except for he says it for
real
yes he's not joking yeah yeah he's being
serious yeah and forrest gump was made
way after so that's interesting
yeah you know i wonder if there's some
sort of a through line or something well
i don't know i'll i'll call tom hanks up
and ask him that question
gary we had gary sinise on the podcast
yeah he was pretty good briefing on it
he definitely
said it yeah i like gary yeah you can't
you cannot
not like gary great great guy a huge
supporter he's a huge supporter of the
military of america
uh sir you got anything else you want to
add no no you guys
i hope i answered all your questions
we're just getting warmed up
i will tell you of the three books
people ask me this okay you wrote three
books which one's the best
in my opinion lumps on 719's the best
uh people that have read that have
called me up and they said
i'm crying i've read this thing it's
intense
and and i will warn you right now if you
thought the combat scenes in the first
one were
intense that one there is just
unbelievable it is absolutely
unbelievable what those guys went
through
in in flying that operation uh
i just can't say enough about it the
bravery uh the determination the
dedication the loyally the courage
well you know what would be awesome is
if um if you've got any friends or you
know anyone that was there
and they want to come on here and and
talk about it and talk us through the
book
that'd be awesome how many would you
like to have them at one time
we'll i'll have them all at some point
you know you can if
anyone wants to come on this with this
that's what this podcast is for
i will i will i know i know the guy in
particular uh
that i will i will call him up and ask
him if he'll come talk to you about it
because uh
he was an integral part he was part of
the comancheros
and uh and they did a great job of
course every one of the units
the the blue dolphins uh the robin hoods
that were at like a with us one up there
they all just
amazing what they did and how they did
it and uh
you know when you go into a battle and
you lose in 45 days 600 aircraft
1100 crew members uh and you still
accomplish the missions just
unbelievable what they went through but
yeah
i will call one guy in particular and
and see if he'll
he'll come out and sit down with you
open invite to anybody you send me
there the chair is waiting for them it'd
be an honor to have them on and it's
you know you're talking about it's
incredible what they did but as far as
i'm
as far as i can tell as far as i know
what you all did over there was
incredible
and and well thanks for joining us today
and and more important thanks for thanks
for your incredible service and your
incredible sacrifice
and we won't forget we we will not let
it we will we will not forget
what you all did and we will not forget
your brothers that did not come home
well thank you very much jaco for having
me in for those thoughts
thanks for joining us sir thank you
and with that colonel matt
jackson has left the building
and we are here um echo charles yes sir
another guest another
another example of how much more we
can do as human beings yeah
so i'm going to think something for us
to think about
because we should want to do more right
so yeah in our lives
yeah we should want to we should want to
get better and be better
any suggestions on how we do that yeah
plenty but but the part where you know
when he was talking about i forget the
term when how they got a lower and they
got a
you know when you go through the jungle
yeah with the helicopter
i probably felt that part it was making
me kind of nervous like yeah
imagining there's not a lot of times
when i read stuff
and actually i didn't read those
sections because
it was a lot of dialogue and the
dialogue would be like hold left pull
left tail and you know it's just like
this dialogue going back and forth
i don't i didn't think i could do the
dialogue justice yeah
so i just asked him to kind of describe
what it was like
but yeah crazy crazy stuff the whole
thing
just the fact that those helicopters are
basically like
a 1968 vw
bug yeah like they got an engine they
got a steering wheel
you know there's not a lot of there's no
computers in this
yeah just completely manually being
maneuvered
through space and he made a good point
too that like you kind of don't think
about compared to
when he compared it to airplanes where
it's like bro the helicopter is all you
the airplane a lot of time you can sort
of let it cruise you know
yeah where the helicopter is like man
you you
can't wait to tell that to dave burke
good deal you know yeah exactly
exactly either way all right cool yes
we're all improving trying to believe
we're on the path yep
i'm on the path i used to say maybe one
way
to try and improve is seeing how quickly
we could get through certain tasks oh
yeah yeah like efficient
yeah efficiency getting more efficient
as opposed to rushing it because we
don't want to rush nothing or do we i
don't know am i wrong
should i should we rush it um
i'm thinking we could probably move more
quick more quickly more efficient
efficiently i get it um i know you think
that there's a bunch of people that are
listening
they're not they're not they're not
listening they shut it off
they they heard uh colonel jackson left
the building like oh cool
let me get back 70 minutes of my time
right now because i can just press stop
on this podcast
all right okay all right okay i got you
i got you hey look we're all
we're all in the path we may need some
help how about that we'll supplement
our selves with supplementation
from jocko see that right there that
whole sentence did not need to exist
right it exists and it has it has a
massive value first off
okay i'm just saying look hey look if
i'm about to give you some help
how should i should
should i declare that i am here to help
if you need help
okay or or could use help i'm just
saying you know what you're not saying
you should tell us what we need to know
okay all right i'm over here trying but
you're over here
you that's the thing i bring this on
myself
yes i should just be totally silent yeah
yeah well okay
i don't know i don't know about all that
okay uh how can we help ourselves echo
through supplementation choco fuel
you got problems with your joints or you
don't want to ever worry about your
joints anymore take supercrew oil and
joint warfare boom
you want vitamin d three supplementation
which is good for
all aspects of health if you care about
that
which we do because we're on the path
boom choco is that
that as well also you want some
additional protein we got milk and it
tastes good how about that
it's true put a banana in there that's
what i do sometimes
also we got discipline and discipline go
which are at its core
i like the fact that i tell you to hurry
and i tell you that
everybody already knows all this and you
still tell this stuff to me like i'm
hearing it for the first time well
you're looking at me like hearing it for
the first time
some of us either didn't hear it or
it's cool to get a reminder okay you
assuming yep
all right everyone's reminded good stuff
yeah supplementation look hey get the
discipline go i was i was going to go
into this
earlier off air but the so if you drink
energy drinks yep i don't care if you
get the sugar-free one
but it's like at a certain point usually
after the first one
if you taller if you're even into it
after the first one you're like brownie
i can't do these anymore at least for
for a day
your body knows and they it tells your
mind this is not good
that is the point right there yep yeah
it's like your body knows yeah your body
knows
what there's something wrong with this
one jocko discipline go
it it your body still knows your body
knows it's good
yeah your body says hey i could use a
little bit more of that so bro if you're
listening to a four-hour
vietnam pilot scenario bro those things
just keep rolling
with it with a smile i'll tell you that
yeah yeah hey if you want to get any of
this stuff and you want to get it
shipped to your house
for free go to jockofield.com and then
what you can do is subscribe
if you subscribe to it'll come to your
house for free anything that you want
in this category of supplementation you
can also get the drinks at wawa
you can also get the whole line at
vitamin
shop jockofield.com get some
uh also origin usa.com
you can get this stuff there as well uh
also jiu-jitsu stuff and when we're
doing
our jiu jitsu we want some new stuff a
new ghee just face it we could
with uh colonel jackson we could have
gone down he's trained at the codacon
judo
we could have gone down that well that's
a two-hour three-hour podcast yeah
didn't even get there yet
because when that guy was coming when
when lieutenant dick weed was coming
at him right yeah that guy was about to
get
judo tossed right on his head
so that's what i'm talking about so
jiu-jitsu we're doing jiu-jitsu sorry
but yeah origin usa i'm saying if you
you know you want to get some new jiu
jitsu stuff
boom that's where you get it all made in
america by the way i say it i say by the
way but it's a huge deal here's the
thing though if
let's say you need stuff beyond just jiu
jitsu stuff like you got your jiu jitsu
stuff handled you got the ghee you got
the rash guard
you still might need to go to the
grocery store
you can't wear the guitar grocery store
what you can wear is american-made jeans
yep not to mention what you can make it
is american-made boots
it's true you can get it all there and
don't think
100 work industrial like this that but
let's face it there's some
i know you don't like the word fashion
but there's some fashion in there leave
it to pete
there's some function there okay yeah
pete roberts bleeds over in some
some situ scenarios uh put it this way
he added a significant amount of
aesthetic
value to both by the way jeans and boots
i don't
agree you just can't see that kind of
stuff no it's just functional yeah yeah
yeah
like i said like i said you can't really
see that kind of stuff but
nonetheless it is there so yes origin
usa that's the spot to get these
items also choco has a store so called
jack store this is where you can get
your t-shirts that say discipline equals
freedom good
death core uh take the high ground
hardcore recondos hardcore
condos i like when somebody comes onto
twitter or the gram
and says you should make a shirt that
says back to the book or you should make
a shirt that says this link was freedom
or you should make whatever
right and i go to chocolatestore.com
yeah
it's right there yeah i'm not saying
we've thought of every shirt by any
stretch
but there's a bunch of shirts there
speaking of thinking of
every shirt so we've expanded
into a subscription scenario and this is
where we can
experiment for lack of a better term
with all
other ideas for shirts every idea pretty
much
what's this thing called the shirt
locker see that's a good name
what did you originally call it i forget
that was a long time ago i forget well
are you trying to block that further you
know from your mind like i said i am
it's a good it's a good little
deal it's fun check that one out again
dracostore.com
if you like something you know get
something
uh you can also subscribe to this
podcast
there's not just this podcast also
there's jocko unraveling myself and
daryl cooper of martyr made fame
is he famous from martyr maid yes in my
mind he is uh you can check out jocko
unraveling we're talking about a bunch
of different
things historical things and how they
tie into what's going on right now we've
got the grounded podcast we've got
warrior kit podcasts have some new
episodes up there
you can also check us out at the
jockonunderground.com
this is look it's a what do they call it
paywall yeah i always say firewall yeah
you correct me
yeah what's the difference uh firewall
is a security thing
has nothing to do with paying okay so we
have a thing that you can pay
it costs eight dollars and eighteen
cents a month it's basically you're
supporting
this podcast you're supporting all these
podcasts that we're doing
and also we have a contingency plan in
case we get
removed for whatever reason or if we
we hear that other platforms
are injecting advertisements into our
podcast we don't like that i don't like
that
i don't want to have colonel matt
jackson talking about flying a mission
to vietnam and have somebody
edit in a freaking advertisement so we
don't want that
we don't want that uh so that's why we
made jockowunderground.com we also
we also put a little additional podcast
on there just to
say thanks so we appreciate it if you're
if you're helping us out there
you're you're helping us remain free
so go to jocklowunderground.com if you
want to help out there we also have a
youtube channel
a youtube channel because echo charles
is a youtuber
technically you're the youtuber
technically so you know
charles is a youtuber and he wants you
to subscribe to his youtube channel
where he posts youtube videos
first okay first off the youtube channel
is called jocko podcast and doesn't have
echo in there at all
ever pretty much maybe in some of the
titles
yes what's the difference between a
youtuber and somebody that's posting
youtube videos i don't think there is
one yes there is well
i don't know i guess if you go through
youtube youtube no youtuber is that
that's their primary occupation is to
be on youtube but then again even that
yeah that that is it i think as far as i
know
there's some really legit
youtubers out there that make freaking
awesome stuff and
and post it yeah fully there's also a
lot of youtubers out there
it's hard to throw them in that same
bucket with the awesome yeah the
awesomeness so
i think you're more in the bucket of
like you know
wait all right what's the next section
anyway all right cool good i mean you're
a youtuber i'm a youtuber
no that's not our primary so technically
we're not youtubers we have a youtube
channel
and it is yeah i think it's legitimate
okay so check that out if you want all
right also psychological warfare is an
album that jocko made we made
of draco telling you how to get through
moments of weakness i was actually
telling you
yeah telling me no it's everybody not
everybody that wants
because we all have them from time to
time you see what i'm saying but yeah
you can get that anywhere where you
where you get mp3s whether it be amazon
google play boom that's where you can
get them also also you want a visual
representation you want things to hang
on your wall basically yep hopefully
go to go to flipsidecampus.com my
brother dakota meyer he's got a company
made in america
making cool stuff to hang on your wall
which is legit bunch of books
we've got a bunch of books we got the
books that we talked about today the
book we talked about today primarily
was undaunted valor an assault
helicopter unit vietnam there's also
volume 2 medal of honor and volume 3
which matt jackson colonel jackson said
was the best of the three
about about lamson in uh
17 718 largest air battle
um final spin i have a novel coming out
myself
and it's a story it's a book
it's a poem it's a new form of
writing am i allowed to do that
we don't know yeah i don't know if i'm
allowed to do it but i did it
it's a story if you want to get final
spin if you want that first a dish
boy that first dish is going to be legit
all right hey if you want the first to
dish order it because
guess what the publisher's thinking the
publisher's like well you know jocko you
uh you mostly write books about
leadership so you know what
what's this thing over here they're not
going to print enough they're not going
to print enough and then it'll come out
you'll be mad because you've got the
third to dish brutal
shame just shame
[Laughter]
uh leadership strategy and tactics field
manual the code the evaluation the
protocols display equals freedom field
manual way of the warrior kid one two
three and
four mikey and the dragons about face
this is getting to be a long list isn't
it yes sir and then the
the original books extreme ownership and
the dichotomy of leadership that i wrote
with my brother leif babin
also we have echelon front which is our
leadership consulting company
we solve problems through leadership go
to ashlandfront.com if you want us to
help
inside your company we have ef online
which is
online training for leadership you can
get your whole organization
into the game go to efonline.com for
that
muster our leadership events we are
executing
we didn't execute in 2020. there was the
virus and
whatnot we were about to execute one in
2020 and guess what happened
i got the virus i got it i had i had
miss rona
yeah and so when i had miss rona i
couldn't go spread it to everybody
so we we didn't execute any in 2021
we are 100 executing in 2021
orlando may 25th and 26th phoenix
phoenix august 17th and 18th and las
vegas
october 28th and 29th go to extreme
ownership.com
everything that we've done has sold out
these are going to sell out too
especially because we got
a little less people for social
distancing and whatnot
so less seats so they're going to sell
out if you want to come
go to extremeownership.com asap we have
ef battlefield
which is us for this particular one the
next one we've got up
is us walking the battlefield at
gettysburg
this is a small number of people
attending very small it's like 35
people so if you want to come
go to slumfront.com events you can sign
up for that or you can sign up for the
ftx we do
combat missions simulated combat
missions to teach leadership
awesome stuff if you want to help
service members
active and retired if you want to help
their families if you want to help gold
star families check out
mark lee's mom mama lee she's got a
charity organization and if you want to
donate or you want to get involved go to
america's mighty warriors
and if you want any more i mean if you
just feel like you need more of my
protracted pontifications or you need
more of ekko's
confounding catechisms
you can find us on the interwebs on
twitter
on the gram or on that facebook
echoes that equity charles and i am at
jocko willink and thanks once again
to colonel matt jackson for joining us
and for writing these books but most
important
for his service to america and we will
not forget the fallen soldiers
of the 227th assault helicopter
battalion
freedom is not free and thanks to all
the other men and women out there in
uniform who are always on watch
and ready to protect and defend our way
of life and that includes not only the
military but also
police and law enforcement firefighters
paramedics emts dispatchers
correctional officers border patrol
secret service
and all the other first responders thank
you for protecting and defending us
as well and to everyone else
remember the price that was paid for our
freedom
and in the book undaunted valor there's
a part that i did not read today
this is where dan corey
and his team fly to an out station to
pick up some bodies of
two soldiers that were killed in action
and they arrive on scene
and the two fallen servicemen wrapped in
ponchos are are loaded
onto the old huey warbor warbird
and dan corey whispers a prayer
that he had written he says
may they soar with the angels on wings
of eagles
may they watch over those they loved and
those
who love them may they rest in peace
until we gather for the final formation
amen
and that's all i've got for tonight
and until next time this is echo and
jocko
out